I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind-the-scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Oh, that can only mean one thing. Welcome to a day that I never thought would happen on our podcast. I never thought it would happen either, but it is Office Ladies 6.0 and really anything can happen. So brace yourself because today it's, as Jenna titled it, Office Ladies do Game of Thrones.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极的《办公室》粉丝播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量的VFF（非常好的朋友）故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。哦，那只能意味着一件事。欢迎来到我从未想过会在我们的播客中发生的一天。我也从未想过会发生，但现在是《办公室女士》6.0版，真的什么都可能发生。所以做好准备，因为今天正如珍娜所命名的，是《办公室女士》演绎《权力的游戏》。
Just winter is coming. Okay. Just the first episode. We're not gonna go crazy. We're not doing all of Game of Thrones. Not yet. I'm holding out hope. All right, so here's what's happening today.
只是“凛冬将至”。好吧。只是第一集。我们不会疯狂的。我们不会做完整个《权力的游戏》。还没到那时候。我抱有希望。好了，这就是今天的内容。
We are gonna be discussing Winter is Coming. It is the first episode in the Game of Thrones series. And for those of you who know the world, you know the series is based on A Song of Ice and Fire, which is a book series by George R.R. Martin. And it was written for television by creators David Benioff and D.B. Weiss. And this first episode was directed by Tim Van Patten.
我们将讨论《凛冬将至》。这是《权力的游戏》系列的第一集。对于那些了解这个世界的人来说，你们知道该系列改编自乔治·R·R·马丁的系列小说《冰与火之歌》。它由创作者大卫·贝尼奥夫和D·B·威斯为电视编写。这一集由蒂姆·范·帕顿执导。
I would like to point out that Angela came dressed today in a Mother of Dragons t-shirt. Hell yeah! And you know I have owned it for probably a decade. I also bought Josh a shirt that said winter is coming. And we might have posed together in both of them holding our kids' Nerf swords. You might have? I might have. You definitely did.
我想指出，安吉拉今天穿了一件“龙妈”T恤。太棒了！而且你知道我可能已经拥有它十年了。我还给乔什买了一件写着“凛冬将至”的衬衫。我们可能穿着这两件衣服，拿着孩子们的玩具泡沫剑合影了。你们可能拍了？我可能拍了。你绝对拍了。
I definitely did. Well, lady, I might have. You definitely did. I definitely did. Well, lady, I am actually excited to dive into this with you. I did watch the first two to three seasons of Game of Thrones once in my life, and I enjoyed revisiting this pilot. Why don't we go old school,
我绝对拍了。好吧，女士，我可能拍了。你绝对拍了。我绝对拍了。好吧，女士，我真的很兴奋能和你一起深入探讨这个话题。我这辈子只看过一次《权力的游戏》的前两到三季，我很享受重温这一集试播集。我们为什么不复古一下，
and why don't you give us a summary, lady? Maybe some fast facts? Let's do it. I know you normally write a summary, lady? Maybe some fast facts? Let's do it. I know you normally write a summary, but I thought because this is my special show that I would tackle the summary. So here goes. I love it.
你为什么不给我们做一个总结呢，女士？也许来点快讯？我们开始吧。我知道你通常会写总结，女士？也许来点快讯？我们开始吧。我知道你通常会写总结，但我想因为这是我的特别节目，所以我想由我来负责总结。所以开始了。我喜欢。
Lord Stark is troubled by news of a deserter from the Night's Watch and the death of his friend, Hand of the King Jon Arryn. Meanwhile, King Robert Baratheon and the Lannisters arrive at the Stark home in Winterfell, where the young Bran Stark climbs a turret and accidentally witnesses an incestuous affair between Jaime and Cersei Lannister, leading to his tragic fall slash push from Jaime Lannister. And listen, this was a very far fall.
史塔克公爵被守夜人逃兵的消息以及他的朋友、国王之手琼恩·艾林的死所困扰。与此同时，劳勃·拜拉席恩国王和兰尼斯特家族抵达了史塔克在临冬城的家，年轻的布兰·史塔克爬上一座塔楼，意外目睹了詹姆和瑟曦·兰尼斯特之间的乱伦私情，导致他悲剧性地坠落，或者说是被詹姆·兰尼斯特推下。听着，这可是摔得很远。
I mean, what the F, Jamie. Meanwhile, across the Narrow Sea. That's part of your summary. Yes, it is. A little sidebar. It is. Well, I like an Angela summary. It has some spice.
我是说，搞什么鬼，詹姆。与此同时，在狭海对岸。那是你总结的一部分。是的，没错。一个小插曲。是的。好吧，我喜欢安吉拉的总结。它很有料。
It has some spice. Meanwhile, across the Narrow Sea, Viserius Targaryen brokers a marriage deal between his sister, Denarius, and Khal Drogo of the Dothraki. He's trying to secure an army to reclaim the Iron Throne. And let's not forget, winter is coming and we witnessed our first White Walker. It's true.
它很有料。与此同时，在狭海对岸，韦赛里斯·坦格利安促成了一桩婚姻交易，将他的妹妹丹妮莉丝嫁给多斯拉克人的卡奥卓戈。他试图获得一支军队来夺回铁王座。别忘了，凛冬将至，我们目睹了第一个异鬼。这是真的。
I have some questions and maybe I'll pose the first one now. Okay. This Iron Throne that that brother is after. Yeah, Viserys. That's not the King of the Lord's place. What's it called? The King of the Lord's place.
我有一些问题，也许我现在先提第一个。好的。那个兄弟追求的铁王座。是的，韦赛里斯。那不是国王领主的地方吗？那叫什么？国王领主的地方。
What's it called? There's Winterfell and then there's the House of the... The Red Keep. Westeros? Westeros? King Robert Baratheon? Yeah. Where does he live?
那叫什么？有临冬城，还有……红堡。维斯特洛？维斯特洛？劳勃·拜拉席恩国王？是的。他住在哪里？
That's his throne. Oh, so he is trying to get the throne. Yes. From... Robert. Okay, there's only one throne. Yes. Okay, I was a little bit confused.
那是他的王座。哦，所以他是在试图得到那个王座。是的。从……劳勃那里。好吧，只有一个王座。是的。好吧，我有点困惑。
Yeah. There's one throne. And that's why Robert... It's called Game of Thrones. I know. So I thought maybe there were several thrones in play. Well, castles have their thrones, but this is the big mama-jamma. Okay. Okay, of thrones.
是的。只有一个王座。这就是为什么劳勃……它叫《权力的游戏》。我知道。所以我以为可能有好几个王座在争夺。好吧，城堡里有各自的王座，但这是最大的那个。好的。好的，关于王座。
Got it. That's why later we'll get to it, Robert is worried about this Targaryen gal getting married to the Dothraki. I missed that. OK. I missed that. That's not a good sign.
明白了。这就是为什么稍后我们会讲到，劳勃担心这个坦格利安女孩嫁给多斯拉克人。我错过了那个。好的。我错过了那个。那不是个好兆头。
OK. All right, go on. I do want to give a cast shout out. There are 43 cast members in this first episode. They're all phenomenal. It's an amazing group of actors. I'm not going to list them all, because there are 43 cast members in this first episode. They're all phenomenal. It's an amazing group of actors. I'm not gonna list them all because there's 43 and we'd be here. But if anyone wants to know an actor's name as we're going through this breakdown, I have the full pilot cast list.
好的。好吧，继续。我确实想向演员阵容致敬。这一集里有43位演员。他们都很出色。这是一个了不起的演员群体。我不会把他们全部列出来，因为这一集里有43位演员。他们都很出色。这是一个了不起的演员群体。我不会把他们全部列出来，因为有43个人，我们会在这儿待很久。但如果有人想知道我们在解析过程中提到的演员名字，我有完整的试播集演员名单。
Should you say, Ange, who played that role? I can tell you. Okay. Okay. Now let's get into some fast facts. I can't wait. Fast fact number one. According to Ranker.com, this Game of Thrones pilot that aired on April 17th, 2011 is as of January 2025, that's this year, it is still considered the number one television pilot ranked by fans. Oh. That's kind of amazing. That is really amazing.
你应该说，安吉，是谁扮演的那个角色？我可以告诉你。好的。好的。现在让我们进入一些快讯。我等不及了。快讯第一条。根据Ranker.com的数据，这部于2011年4月17日播出的《权力的游戏》试播集，截至2025年1月，也就是今年，仍然被粉丝评为第一名的电视试播集。哦。这真是太神奇了。这真的很神奇。
Are you curious to hear the top five? I am. Good, because- Are you gonna tell me? Yes. Do you have other thoughts? You paused, you looked off to the side. I have a personal favorite pilot episode of a show.
你好奇想听听前五名吗？我很想。很好，因为——你要告诉我吗？是的。你还有别的想法吗？你停顿了一下，看向了一边。我有一个个人最喜欢的剧集试播集。
It's Breaking Bad. Is it on the list? Would you let me do the list, lady? Yes, I'm curious. Okay, I was gonna say, wait and see if it's on the list. Okay, here are the top five pilots on ranker.com. Number one, Game of Thrones. Number two, The Walking Dead.
是《绝命毒师》。它在名单上吗？你能让我念完名单吗，女士？是的，我很好奇。好吧，我本来想说，等着看它是否在名单上。好的，这是Ranker.com上的前五名试播集。第一名，《权力的游戏》。第二名，《行尸走肉》。
I would agree that is a very good pilot. I don't even like zombie stuff, but I watched that pilot and I was like, dang, that was good. Number three, Breaking Bad. Okay, okay. Very good pilot. Number four, Lost. I would agree. Really good. Okay. Number three, Breaking Bad. Okay. Okay. Very good pilot. Number four, Lost. I would agree. Really good. Really good. Scared the crap out of me. Number five, The Simpsons. Huh. Only one comedy on the list. Yeah. So yes, the pilot performed very well and the show was a hit. But there was soon to
我同意那是一个非常好的试播集。我甚至不喜欢僵尸题材，但我看了那个试播集，我就觉得，天哪，那太棒了。第三名，《绝命毒师》。好的，好的。非常好的试播集。第四名，《迷失》。我同意。真的很好。好的。第三名，《绝命毒师》。好的。好的。非常好的试播集。第四名，《迷失》。我同意。真的很好。真的很好。吓死我了。第五名，《辛普森一家》。哈。名单上只有一部喜剧。是的。所以是的，试播集表现非常好，该剧也大获成功。但很快就出现了一些
be some online snobbery. Oh, was it book people versus show people? Because it was based on a book? Well, there's lots of that. There's a very funny meme that's like, the people that read the book can't wait to tell you they read the books. But the one that got me tickled and cracked me up, because I thought it was really spot on, was,
网络势利眼。哦，是书迷对剧迷吗？因为它是根据书改编的？嗯，有很多这种情况。有一个非常有趣的梗，大意是，读过书的人迫不及待地想告诉你他们读过书。但那个让我觉得很有趣并让我大笑的，因为我觉得它真的很到位，是，
and I printed one to show you, and I'll share it in stories. So for all the thousands of people who loved Game of Thrones and they were watching it, in every friend group, there was that one person and they were so proud of themselves and they would say, I'm not watching it, I'm not watching it. And look at this meme and you know,
我打印了一张给你看，我会分享在故事里。所以对于成千上万喜欢《权力的游戏》并观看它的人来说，在每个朋友圈里，都有那么一个人，他们对自己非常自豪，他们会说，我没看，我没看。看看这个梗，你知道，
each episode came out every week. So this was one of the memes I saw one week that cracked me up. It said, only one more week until people who don't watch Game of Thrones tell everyone they don't watch Game of Thrones. That's very funny. Come on, that's funny. That was me. That was you. Okay, moving on to fast fact number two, and I should say Jenna is going to do fast fact three. I am. Yeah, fast fact number two. I call this locations and a trailer. Locations and a trailer. It's got a title, my fast fact. The Winter is Coming episode was filmed in several locations in Iceland and Northern Ireland.
每一集每周都会出来。所以这是我某一周看到的让我大笑的梗之一。上面写着，再过一周，那些不看《权力的游戏》的人就会告诉所有人他们不看《权力的游戏》。这太搞笑了。得了吧，这很有趣。那是我。那是你。好的，进入快讯第二条，我应该说珍娜将负责快讯第三条。是我。是的，快讯第二条。我称之为“地点和预告片”。地点和预告片。我的快讯有个标题。这一集《凛冬将至》是在冰岛和北爱尔兰的几个地点拍摄的。
Specifically, Iceland's icy landscapes and dramatic scenery that were used to portray the harsh conditions north of the wall, where the threat, you know, of the White Walkers was. Very snowy. Very snowy. And in March of 2011, HBO released the very first trailer for Game of Thrones. And it's pretty long, but I thought we should hear a little snippet of it. Oh, okay.
具体来说，冰岛冰冷的景观和戏剧性的风景被用来描绘长城以北的恶劣条件，那里有异鬼的威胁。非常多雪。非常多雪。2011年3月，HBO发布了《权力的游戏》的第一支预告片。它很长，但我认为我们应该听一小段。哦，好的。
Get us in the mood. Okay. I, Eddard of the House Stark, Lord of Winterfell and Warden of the North sentence you to die. I saw what I saw. I saw the White Walkers. You understand why I did it? It was the Deserter. The man who passes a sentence... ...should swing the sword.
让我们进入状态。好的。我，史塔克家族的艾德，临冬城公爵兼北境守护，判处你死刑。我看到了我所看到的。我看到了异鬼。你明白我为什么这么做吗？那是逃兵。执行判决的人……应该挥动剑。
Is it true he saw the white walkers? A madman sees what he sees. Fear and blood. A lot of suspense. A lot of great dialogue. Great dialogue. The madman sees what the madman sees. Yeah. And you must have loved that one about the man who
他真的看到异鬼了吗？疯子看到他所看到的。恐惧和鲜血。很多悬念。很多精彩的对话。精彩的对话。疯子看到疯子所看到的。是的。你一定很喜欢那句关于执行判决的人必须挥动剑的话。为什么，你怎么知道我喜欢那个？因为它有点前卫。确实。它非常前卫。一个人能做到的，另一个人也能做到。是的。是的。是的。我在那里为你感受到了。好吧，伙计们，这就是我快讯的结尾。我们还有很多有趣的东西要穿插进来。珍娜有快讯第三条，伙计们，这可是个重磅炸弹。你即将分享一些真正伟大的幕后内容。是的。
makes the sentence has to swing the sword. Why would, how did you know I liked that? Because it's kind of edgy. It is. It's very the edge. What one man can do another can. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I felt it for you there. Well you guys those are the end of my fast facts. We have a bunch of fun stuff we're going to sprinkle through. Jenna has Fast Fact number three, and you guys, it's a doozy. Some real great behind-the-scenes stuff you're about to share. Yeah.
我对《权力的游戏》的演员阵容印象深刻，所以我还去IMDb查看了演员名单。当然。就像，这些我现在知道很有名的演员是谁，但实际上他们中的很多人是因为这部剧而出名的？当我在四处查看时，我看到在《凛冬将至》之前还有一集。试播集之前的试播集？
I was so impressed with the cast of Game of Thrones that I also went to IMDb to look at the cast list. Sure. Like, who are these actors that I know are now famous, but were really a lot of them made famous by this show? And while I was poking around, I saw that there was an episode before Winter Is Coming. The pilot before the pilot?
试播集之前的试播集。有一个未播出的《权力的游戏》试播集。是的。它是用胶片拍摄的。《凛冬将至》和该系列的其他部分都是用数字拍摄的，但这个原始试播集是在《凛冬将至》播出前一年用胶片拍摄的。我对此变得非常好奇。
The pilot before the pilot. There is an unaired pilot for Game of Thrones. Yes. It was shot on film. Winter Is Coming and the rest of the series were all shot on digital, but this original pilot was shot on film like a year before Winter is Coming came out. I became so curious about it.
我深入研究了一下，我想它并不好。我喜欢他们展示这部电影的朋友对它的评价。你看到那个评价了吗？是的。他说什么？是的。我的意思是，他基本上说，这是垃圾。这完全是一堆垃圾。
I was deep diving it and I guess it was not good. I love the quote by their friend that they showed the film to. Did you see the quote? Yes. What he said? Yeah. I mean, he basically was like, it's garbage. It is a bunch of garbage.
是的。他说就像，重头再来。是的，没错。所以他们确实这样做了。他们重写了剧本，重拍了几乎所有的内容。而且他们不得不更换一些演员。是的，两位女演员退出了。他们更换了奈德·史塔克的妻子和丹妮莉丝的角色。他们不得不几乎完全重拍那个未播出的试播集的原因之一是，
Yeah. He said like, start over. Yeah, exactly., he basically was like, it's garbage. It is a bunch of garbage. Yeah, he said like, start over. Yeah, exactly. So they did. They rewrote the script and they reshot almost all of it. And they had to recast some people. Yes, two actresses dropped out. They recast the role of Ned Stark's wife and Daenerys. One of the reasons that they had to like almost completely
他们没有更换孩子们的演员，到他们重拍的时候，他们都大了一岁。是的。他们不得不重做，这样他们才能匹配。我想很多创意决定都被重新修改了。例如，他们改变了异鬼的外观以及他们的行为方式。此外，原始试播集并没有真正包含兰尼斯特双胞胎之间的乱伦关系。我想它包含了他们处于一段关系中，但对人们来说并不清楚
reshoot that pilot that didn't air was because they did not recast the kids and they were all like a year older by the time they got around to like reshooting. Yeah. And they had to redo it so that they would match. I guess a lot of creative decisions were reworked. For example, they changed the look of the white walkers and how they acted. Also, the original pilot did not really include the incestuous relationship between the Lannister twins. I guess it included that they were in a relationship, but it was not clear to people
他们是兄妹。所以我不知道你是否注意到在《凛冬将至》中，她对她哥哥说的第一句台词就是，你好，哥哥。就像，这次我们要立刻把这一点说清楚。我觉得那非常有趣。我想还有一句台词是他们说，那是瑟曦的孪生兄弟。是的。他们这次真的把这一点强调得很到位，所以最后那一幕非常非常清楚。我想有一本书出版了，叫《火不能杀死龙》，里面有各种各样关于这个未播出试播集的演员和剧组的采访，我发现了很多更酷的趣闻，我
that they were brother and sister. So I don't know if you notice in Winter is Coming, literally the first line that she says to her brother is, hello brother. Like, we're gonna make this clear right away this time. I thought that was very funny. There's also a line I think where they're like, that's Cersei's twin. Yes. They were really, they really hammer it home this time so that final scene is very very clear. I guess there was a book that came out it's called Fire Cannot Kill a Dragon and it has all kinds of interviews from the cast and crew about this unaired pilot and I found a lot of more cool tidbits I'm
会在我们解析的时候穿插进去。但我发现这一切都挺迷人的。是的。我不敢相信HBO给了他们预算去重拍。这显示了他们有多么支持。他们就像，你知道吗？这在好莱坞是不会发生的。你不能只是重来一次。重来。是的。不。
gonna sprinkle them throughout when we break it down. But I just found it all kind of fascinating. Yeah. I can't believe that HBO gave them the budget to reshoot it. That shows how behind it they were. They were like, you know what? That does not happen in Hollywood. You do not just get to do over. A do over. Yeah. No.
这也表明了他们有多么信任他们的朋友，那个他们展示给看的人，克雷格·麦辛，当他觉得，呃，啊。是的，克雷格·麦辛，负责改编《最后生还者》的那位。我不得不认为他在《权力的游戏》中看到了佩德罗·帕斯卡，并想，那个人是谁？总有一天我们必须看佩德罗·帕斯卡的那一集。好的，这是我在进入这个话题之前的愿望清单。在我们解析完这个之后，在未来的某个时候，
It just also goes to show how much they trusted their friend, who they showed it to, Craig Mason, when he was like, eh, ah. Yes, Craig Mason, who was in charge of adapting The Last of Us. I have to think he saw Pedro Pascal in Game of Thrones and was like, who's that guy? Someday we have to watch the episode with Pedro Pascal. Okay, here's my wish list before we get into this. After we break this down, somewhere down the road,
不需要很快，我会让你从《权力的游戏》中喘口气，珍娜。好的。我想让你看我们见到佩德罗·帕斯卡的那一集。我加入，我的意思是，没问题。没问题，然后我还真的很想让你看“红色婚礼”，
doesn't have to be anytime soon, I'll let you have a breather from Game of Thrones, Jenna. Okay. I want you to watch the episode where we meet Pedro Pascal. I'm in, I mean, done. Done, and then I also really want you to watch the Red Wedding,
因为我觉得在所有剧集中，那是让我觉得，天哪，这到底是怎么回事的一集？难道不是很多人死在里面吗？嗯，我的意思是，那不是白色婚礼。好的，但我确实想说，我知道佩德罗·帕斯卡在《权力的游戏》中有一个可怕、恐怖的死亡。我看到过一个关于它的采访，
because I think of all the episodes, that was the one where I was like, holy crap sticks, what is happening? Don't like a lot of people die in that? Well, I mean, it's not the white wedding. Okay, but I do want to say that I know that Pedro Pascal has like a horrible, gruesome death in Game of Thrones. I saw an interview about it,
我不知道我是否能再看一次。他在他出场的那一集里没死，对吧？不，当然没有。好的，我的心脏受不了。好的，好吧，我们会看你见到他的那一集。我们见到他的那一集，我会和你一起看这个红色婚礼的事情。我们开始吧。
and I don't know if I can do that again. He doesn't die in the episode where he's introduced, right? No, of course not. Okay, my heart can't take it. Okay, well, we'll watch the one where you meet him. Where we meet him, and I'll watch this red wedding business with you. Let's do it.
好的。好的。好吧，听着，我们休息一下，然后回来的时候，我们要看《权力的游戏》。我等不及了。我看这个的时候给珍娜发了短信，我说，这太荒谬了，这就是我的工作。
Okay. Okay. Well, listen, why don't we take a break, and then when we come back, we are gonna do Game of Thrones. I can't wait. I texted Jenna when I was watching this and I said, this is so ridiculous that this is my job.
我现在太开心了。你太开心了。你从我今天见到你开始就一直在笑。我知道，我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。
I am so happy right now. You're so happy. You've been smiling since I saw you today. I know, I know. I know. I know. I know. I know.
我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。带我们进入这个，安吉。当我们一起看《边缘》时，你真的被风迷住了。哦，好的。你给我放了很多风的声音。
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I bring us into this, Ange. When we watched The Edge together, you were really taken by the wind. Oh, okay. And you played me a lot of audio of wind.
好的。我真的被这部剧的声音设计和声音剪辑迷住了。太棒了。绝对不可思议。我让萨姆抓取了一段开场一分钟的声音片段。哦，我喜欢。让我们听听。我抱歉。你听到最后有一点风声了吗，只是为你，安吉？是的。但你听到了，就像大门打开的声音。只是为你，安吉。是的，是的。
Okay. I was really taken with the sound design and sound editing on this show. It's fantastic. Absolutely incredible. I asked Sam to grab a clip of the opening one minute of sound. Oh, I love it. Let's hear it. the I'm sorry. Do you hear that there's a little wind at the end just for you, Angie? Yeah. But you hear it, it's like gates opening. the end just for you, Angel. Yeah, yeah.
但你听到了。就像大门打开的声音。哦，哦。有马蹄声。那是一个巨大的金属门。然后他们进入这个黑暗的隧道，这三个守夜人。火把的闪烁。是的。
But you hear it. It's like gates opening. Oh, oh. There's clip clops of horses. It's a giant metal gate. And then they go into this dark tunnel, these three men from the Night's Watch. The Torch's Flair. Yeah.
黑暗、冰冷的隧道。然后他们到达另一个更大的金属门。门升起来了。他们从那里出来，你看到那个门被它所嵌入的巨大冰墙的大小衬托得如此渺小。好吧，我得让你知道，这一集的声音设计师是安迪·肯尼迪，你猜怎么着？什么？他凭借《凛冬将至》获得了金卷轴奖最佳电视短片声音剪辑、音效和
Dark, icy tunnel. Then they get to another even bigger metal gate. That goes up. They come out of that, and you see that that gate is so dwarfed by the size of the giant ice wall that it's built into. Well, I'll have you know, the sound designer for this episode was Andy Kennedy, and guess what? What? He won the Golden Real Award for best sound editing, short form, sound effects, and
拟音奖。他还因《权力的游戏》获得了艾美奖提名。他在第一季后离开了该剧，但总的来说，《权力的游戏》以其惊人的声音设计而闻名。它赢得了多个奖项。从第三季开始，宝拉·费尔菲尔德成为该剧的声音设计师，她负责创造
foley in television for Winter is Coming. He was also nominated for an Emmy for Game of Thrones. He left the show in season one, but in general, Game of Thrones was known for its amazing sound design. It won multiple awards. Starting in season three, Paula Fairfield became sound designer for the show, and she is responsible for creating the cries
小龙的叫声。嗯。从零开始，她不得不弄清楚小龙听起来会是什么样子。她和她的团队在2013年、2014年、2016年、2017年获得了艾美奖提名。并在2015年和2019年赢得了艾美奖。现在她是《龙之家族》的声音设计师。
of the baby dragon. Mm. From, like, the ground up, she had to, like, figure out what the baby dragons were going to sound like. She and her team were nominated for an Emmy in 2013, 2014, 2016, 2017. And they won an Emmy in 2015 and 2019. And now she's the sound designer for House of Dragon.
所以……我的意思是，这是《龙之家族》的声音设计师。所以。我的意思是，这是一群杰出的人。在剧集的第一分钟，我就被吸引住了，老实说，这全是声音设计。我的意思是，这大概90%是声音设计。它真的很强大。挺酷的。好吧，伙计们，这三个守夜人现在，
So... I mean, this sound designer for House of Dragon. So. I mean, this is a stellar group of folks. And in the very first minute of the show, I am in, and it's honestly, it's all sound design. I mean, it's like 90% sound design. It's really powerful. Pretty cool. Well, you guys, these three Nights Watchmen are now,
他们越过了长城。他们骑马进入了雪林。有阵雪。这很糟糕。安吉拉的小贴士。什么？如果你在长城以北看到阵雪，糟糕的事情就要发生了。立即离开。
they're beyond the wall. And they ride into the snowy forest. There are snow flurries. This is bad. Angela Hot Tip. What? If you are north of the wall and see snow flurries, bad sh** is about to happen. Leave immediately.
那是凛冬将至吗？凛冬就是异鬼。它们是一回事。什么？凛冬将至。我的意思是，他们一直说它好像有双重含义。威胁等级午夜。凛冬将至。
Is that the winter that's coming? Winter is the white walkers. They are one and the same. What? Winter is coming. I mean, they kept saying it like it had a double meaning. Threat level midnight. Winter is coming.
萨姆。萨姆。我喜欢你现在实时意识到这一点。我真的只是以为冬天要来了。只是冬天。第一次看这部剧的时候，我就想，离冬天还有多久？就像，我们怎么会不知道？
Sam. Sam. I love that you're just realizing this in real time right now. I literally just thought winter was coming. Just winter. And the first time I watched the show, I was like, how much longer till winter? Like, how do we not know?
已经下雪了。冬天不是现在吗？而且，随着剧集的进行，这会变得很烦人。他们引用凛冬将至有一段时间了。是的。不，我知道。我知道。而我心想，一直都在下雪，
It's already snowy. Is winter not now? Also, that's going to get annoying as the show goes on. They reference winter coming for a while. Yeah. No, I know. I know. And I'm like, it's snowing all the time,
但冬天是，冬天会发生什么？坏事。我想是吧。你知道，我的意思是，肯定会有一些真正的困难来到你面前，如果你在长城以北，真的很糟糕。但无论如何，安吉拉的小贴士，你看到阵雪。赶紧离开那里。
but winter is, what happens in winter? The bad stuff. I guess so. You know, I mean, for sure some real hardships come in your way and if you're north of the wall, real bad. But anyway, Angela Hot Tip, you see snow flurries. Get the heck out of there.
好的。好的。现在这些人，他们深入了鬼影森林。他们试图调查这些关于野人失踪的报告。野人是那种住在长城以北的人。他们是一群乌合之众，对吧？好的。
All right. All right. Now the men, they're deeper in the haunted forest. They're trying to investigate these reports of missing wildlings. Wildlings are sort of the people that live beyond the wall. They're kind of a ragtag group of folks, right? Okay.
就像农民一样。呃，我的意思是。森林里的人。呃。萨姆，你会怎么形容野人？是的，他们是野性的。野性的。是的。
Like peasants kind of. Eh, like, I mean. Forest people. Eh. How would you describe wildlings, Sam? Yeah, they're feral. Feral. Yeah.
明白了。他们是野人。他们在这个世界上是野蛮的。明白了。所以我们的一名守夜人，他看到一些烟雾从看起来像营地的地方冒出来，他趴在地上爬过去。你猜怎么着？他被阵雪包围了。
Got it. They're wildlings. They're wild in the world. Got it. So one of our night's watchmen, he sort of sees some smoke coming out of what looks like a camp area, and he gets on the ground and he crawls to it. And guess what? He is surrounded by snow flurries.
错误。不要去那里。但他去了。他去了。他发现了一堆尸体在雪地上排列成某种螺旋图案。是的。我有一个关于那个的趣闻。让我们听听。
Mistake. Do not go there. But he does. He does. And he discovers a bunch of corpses arranged in a kind of spiral pattern in the snow. Yeah. I have a fun fact about that. Let's hear it.
这是对书的一个改动。该系列的编剧增加了尸体会被排列成图案的想法。在剧本中，他们称之为“巫术曼陀罗”。它的设计目的是传达异鬼不是无脑生物的信息。他们想让他们被确立为拥有文化、拥有目的的生物。他们认为这会让他们更可怕。确实，确实。确实，这让他们更可怕。好吧，发现这一点的守夜人，
This was a change from the book. The writers of the series added the idea that the corpses would be arranged in the pattern. In the script, they called it a witchy mandala. And it was designed to send the message that the white walkers were not mindless creatures. They wanted them to be like, established as beings that had a culture, had a purpose. They thought it would make them scarier. It does, it does. It does, it makes them scarier. Well, the night's watchman who discovered this,
他的名字叫威尔，他吓坏了。他跑回他的另外两个朋友那里，他说，嘿，到处都是尸体。我们，你知道，这太疯狂了，我们得离开这里。但他说是他想逃跑。为什么他不想跑回长城？为什么不？那堵墙看起来超级安全。
his name is Will, he is freaked out. He runs back to his other two friends and he's like, hey, there are corpses everywhere. We, you know, this is crazy and as we got to get out of here. But he says he wants to run away. Why doesn't he wanna run back to the wall? Why not? That wall seems super safe.
是因为如果他回到长城，他们会让他再出去，像去战斗无论发生了什么吗？那个我不知道。另一个人说，不，我们应该去长城告诉大家。那是我，我是他。是的。
Is it because if he goes back to the wall, they're gonna make him go out again and like fight whatever's happening? That I don't know. The other guy is like, no, we should go to the wall and tell everyone. That's me, I'm him. Yeah.
但在四分零九秒，有另一个守夜人，留着那种短黑发。还有人觉得他看起来像马特·达蒙吗？当然，是的。还有，珍娜，回答你的问题，答案是肯定的。他们会让他作为守夜人的一员去战斗。好的。
But then at four minutes and nine seconds, there's this other Night's Watchman with kind of short dark hair. Anyone else think he looks like Matt Damon? Sure, yeah. Also the answer to your question, Jenna, would be yes. They would make him go fight as a member of the Night's Watch. Okay.
但等一下，我们能回到马特·达蒙身上一秒钟吗？我道歉，是的。我很抱歉，在整个解析过程中，你和萨姆也将不得不向我解释这部剧。不，不，不。我希望那不会成为。我不介意。我只是掉进了一个兔子洞，那就是，
But wait a second, can we get back to Matt Damon for one second? I apologize, yes. I'm sorry that throughout this breakdown, you and Sam are gonna have to explain the show to me as well. No, no, no. I hope that doesn't become. That I don't mind. I just went down a rabbit hole that is,
问题是马特·达蒙昨晚在《权力的游戏》里吗？而且不是只有我一个人这么想，好吗？看看这个，我做了一个守夜人的并排对比。他扮演的角色是威玛·罗伊斯。在现实生活中，他的名字是罗伯·奥斯勒。看看这个并排对比。哦，天哪。这太疯狂了。整个Reddit线程都在讨论，马特·达蒙在《权力的游戏》里吗？
the question is Matt Damon in Game of Thrones last night. And I was not the only one that thought this, okay? Look at this, I did a side-by-side of the Night's Watchmen. He was playing the character Weymar Royce. And in real life, his name is Rob Ostler. Look at this side-by-side. Oh, my God. That is crazy. There's a whole Reddit thread of, like, is Matt Damon in Game of Thrones?
这就像一件真实的事情。这家伙，他曾经做过马特·达蒙的替身吗？就像，他曾经在电影里演过马特·达蒙的兄弟吗？我找不到。他在BBC One上拍过很多剧集。看看那个。萨姆。是的。
This was like a real thing. Has this guy, has he ever doubled for Matt Damon? Like, has he ever played Matt Damon's brother in a movie? Not that I could find. He's done a bunch of series on BBC One. Look at that. Sam. Yeah.
是的，那非常准确。我的意思是，得了吧。罗伯·奥斯勒和马特·达蒙曾经在同一个房间里被看到过吗？罗伯·奥斯勒有没有可能是马特·达蒙？他就像马特·达蒙的英国对应者？或者这个怎么样？罗伯，厌倦了被定型为严肃、戏剧性的英国作品，
Yeah, that's pretty spot on. I mean, come on. Have Rob Osler and Matt Damon ever been seen in the same room together? Is it possible that Rob Osler is Matt Damon? He's like Matt Damon's British counterpart? Or how about this? Rob, tired of being pigeonholed into like serious, dramatic British work,
采用了化名马特·达蒙，这样他就可以成为像《谍影重重》里的动作明星。但首先他必须和本·阿弗莱克一起写《心灵捕手》。哇，这真是真正的奉献。这是长线骗局。这就是接下来要发生的事情。
took on the alter ego, Matt Damon, so that he could become like an action star in The Bourne Identity. But first he had to write Good Will Hunting with Ben Affleck. Wow, that's some real dedication. This is the long game con. Here's what's gonna happen.
什么？当我见到马特·达蒙时。是的。我的意思是，我见过他一次。这是长线骗局。这就是接下来要发生的事情。什么？当我见到马特·达蒙时。是的。我的意思是，我见过他一次，我记得他在演员工会奖上从我们的桌子上拿走了酒。我记得。但如果我再见到他，你知道我会做什么吗？
What? When I meet Matt Damon. Yep. I mean, I met him one time. This is the long game con. Here's what's gonna happen. What? When I meet Matt Damon. Yep. I mean, I met him one time, I remember he took wine off our table at the SAG Awards. I do remember. But if I ever see him again, you know what I'm gonna do?
什么？我会大喊，罗伯！看看他会做什么？看看他是否会转过身来。看看他是否会转过身来，是的。好的，无论如何。好的，好吧，那个人，不是马特·达蒙，想去看看发生了什么。是的，他就像，不。
What? I'm gonna yell, Rob! And see what he does? See if he turns around. See if he turns around, yeah. Okay, anyway. Okay, well that guy, not Matt Damon, wants to go and see what's up. Yeah, he's like, no.
坏主意的人。我们要回去了。威尔就像，去所有尸体所在的地方？你疯了吗？是的。你猜怎么着？他们回去后，他们都不见了。是的，雪地上连个脚印都没有。
Bad idea guy. We're going back. And Will is like, to where all the corpses are? Are you crazy? Yeah. Guess what? They go back and they're all gone. Yeah, there's not even a footprint in the snow.
这是因为他们都被变成了异鬼僵尸。是的，这就是异鬼杀了你并肢解你之后发生的事情，然后你被重新组合成一个僵尸。你现在才意识到这一点吗，达娜？不，不，不。这个我知道，因为我会说，这是我对这部剧开场的评论。我写下，这部剧开场简直就像一部恐怖电影。
It's because they've all been made into White Walker zombies. Yes, that's what happens after a White Walker kills you and dismembers you, then you get put back together into a zombie. Are you just realizing this right now, Dana? No, no, no. This I knew because I will say, here is my comment on the opening of this show. I wrote down, this show literally opens like a horror movie.
我的意思是，这可能是任何恐怖片的开场。肢解的尸体在雪地上排列成图案，然后那个被钉在树上的女孩现在活着并追赶一个人，然后异鬼把一个人斩首。这简直就是一部僵尸电影。这简直就是《活死人黎明》的开场。我的意思是，这就像同一件事。
I mean, this could be the opening of any horror film. Dismembered bodies arranged in a pattern in the snow, and then the girl that was impaled on the tree is now alive and chasing a guy, and then the white walker beheads a guy. This is literally a zombie movie. It's literally the opening of Dawn of the Dead. I mean, it's like the same thing.
这完全是僵尸。但是的，所以异鬼，你知道，一旦他杀了你，他就可以把你变成异鬼爪牙。你的眼睛变成亮蓝色。是的。但他们确实有一个弱点。对我来说还不清楚。
It's total zombies. But yeah, so the White Walker, you know, once he kills you, then he can make you into a White Walker minion. Your eyes turn bright blue. Yeah. But they do have a weakness. It's not clear to me yet.
还不清楚。好的。它会被揭示。所以无论如何，异鬼，他们杀了两个守夜人，马特·达蒙那个人，还有另一个只想回到长城的人。是的，回到长城，不是马特·达蒙的那个人被杀了，
It's not clear yet. Okay. It will be revealed. So anyway, the White Walkers, they kill two of the Night's Watchmen, the Matt Damon guy, and the other one who just wanted to go back to the wall. Yeah, return to the wall and not Matt Damon get killed,
威尔只是跑开了。他就像在为生命奔跑。是的，然后现在我们有了片头字幕。是的，我确实有一个关于GOT的小知识给你。什么是GOT？哦，《权力的游戏》。啊！萨姆，这会是漫长的一天。
and Will just runs off. He's like running for his life. Yeah, and then now we have the opening credits. Yes, I do have a little GOT trivia for you. What's GOT? Oh, Game of Thrones. Ah! Sam, it's gonna be a long day.
那是GOT。关掉这个。这部剧完了。结束吧。我们甚至还没到开场戏。好的。这是我的……我的大脑不是为这些剧集设计的。我的大脑无法跟随这些。
That's GOT. Shut this down. This show's done. Wrap it up. We haven't even got to the opening scene. Okay. Here is my... My brain was not made for these shows. My brain cannot follow these.
我要抛出一个问题。我要抛出一个问题跟随这些。我不知道那是什么。我要抛出一个问题给你。我太逻辑了。好吧，无论如何，GOT小知识。准备好了吗？是的。听着。异鬼有他们自己的语言。根据对大卫·J·彼得森的采访，我们之前在播客上谈过他。他是创造多斯拉克语的人。
I'm gonna throw a question. I'm gonna throw a question out there follow these. I don't know what is that. I'm gonna throw a question up there for you. I'm too logical. All right, anyway, GOT trivia. Ready? Yes. Get this. The White Walkers had their own language. According to an interview with David J. Peterson, we've talked about him before on the podcast. He's the person who created Dothraki.
没错。他为《权力的游戏》创造了几种语言，他有一种异鬼语言，本来要叫“斯克罗斯”。我在这里引用大卫·J·彼得森的话。他说它实际上是为剧集的第一场戏准备的，异鬼出来并把那个人的头砍掉。有些部分你会听到他们发出咕哝声和发声，但最终“斯克罗斯”被废弃了，因为根据彼得森的说法，我想最终他们决定他们不想让他们真的说东西，甚至加上字幕。老实说，对于剧集的开场戏来说，那可能有点俗气。我喜欢这种想法，他们就像僵尸一样，通过心灵感应交流，或者
That's right. He created several languages for Game of Thrones and he had a white walker language that was going to be called Scroth. I'm quoting David J Peterson here. He says it was actually going to be for the very first scene of the show where the white walker comes out and cuts the guy's head off. There are parts where you hear them kind of grumble and vocalize but ultimately Scroth was scrapped because according to Peterson, I think ultimately they decided they didn't want them to actually say stuff and even subtitle it. That might have been a little corny, honestly, for the opening scene of the show. I like this idea that they just, like zombies do, sort of telepathically communicate or
只是在不同于语言的层面上运作。好吧，这篇文章继续说，对于第二季，声音设计师创造了一种冰裂的声音，最终让这个“斯克罗斯”的想法变成了现实。这是你在看到他们之前或当他们在附近时会听到的声音。所以它有点像一种语言，但没有任何语言化。
just kind of like operate in a different plane than with language. Well, this article went on to say, for season two, the sound designer created an ice cracking sound that finally sort of brought this Scwroth idea to life. It's what you would hear kind of right before you would see them or when they were around. So it's kind of like a language but without any verbalization.
好吧，接下来我们要去我在《权力的游戏》中最喜欢的地方，那就是临冬城和史塔克家族的家。从我之前的观看中，我记得我只是爱上了史塔克家族，爱上了临冬城。我想这是我想住的地方。看起来很棒。这大部分是在爱尔兰拍摄的。你爱爱尔兰。你去过那里。
Well next up we are going to go to my favorite place in Game of Thrones and it is Winterfell and the home of the Stark family. From my previous viewing I remember just loving the Stark family, loving Winterfell. I thought this is where I'd like to live. It seems pretty great. A lot of this was shot in Ireland. You love Ireland. You've been there.
这说得通。嗯哼。我们以那个逃兵威尔开场，他正跑过一座大绿山，后面紧跟着士兵。然后我们在地平线上看到了临冬城。是的。男孩们在练习射箭，
This makes sense. Mm-hmm. While we open on that same deserter, Will, he is running over a big green hill, and closing in behind him are soldiers. And then we see in the horizon Winterfell. Yes. The boys are practicing their bow and arrow shooting,
女孩们在练习缝纫。珊莎真的很擅长。艾莉亚不擅长。你会看到你的第一个经典艾莉亚侧眼。此外，这些女孩的发型会让安吉拉·马丁神魂颠倒。太多的辫子。真正精致的辫子。
and the girls are practicing their sewing. Sansa's really good. Arya is not. You're going to see your very first classic Arya side eye. Also, the hairdos on these girls would make Angela Martin swoon. So many braids. Real elaborate braids.
特别是艾莉亚，顺便说一句，她宁愿去射箭。我们很快就知道她在这方面很擅长。是的，她真的很擅长。比她哥哥好多了。所以我确实必须指出，说到头发，一个老人要接近史塔克家族，系好安全带，迎接一些严肃的面部毛发警报。
Especially Aria, who by the way, would rather be doing the bow and arrow. We learned very soon that like she's pretty good with this. Yeah, she's really good. Much better than her brother. So I do have to point out, speaking of hair, an older man is gonna approach the Stark family, buckle in for some serious facial hair alert.
好的。那是罗德里克·凯塞尔爵士。他是临冬城的武器大师。好的。但他有这些长长的、白色的羊排胡子，顺着脸颊两侧向下，然后在下巴下面汇合，他把它们编成一个小马尾辫。
OK. It's Sir Roderick Castle. He is the master at arms at Winterfell. OK. But he has these long, white lamb chops that go down the side of his cheeks, and then they meet underneath his chin, and he braids them into like a little ponytail.
太疯狂了。我有一个完整的头发解析即将到来。我变得有点痴迷于这部剧里的头发。我去了IMDb查看所有做头发的人。有十几个人，他们的工作是群众头发。有这么多人在这部剧上工作。剧组太庞大了。
It's so crazy. I have a whole hair breakdown coming up. I became a little bit obsessed with the hair on the show. And I went on IMDB looking at all the people who did the hair on the show. And there's like a dozen people whose job was crowd hair. There were so many people who worked on this show. The crew was humongous.
我稍后会有一点可以 piggyback 那个关于服装部门的内容。哦，好的。好吧，我们要了解那个逃兵。史塔克公爵被通知了，所以他就像，好吧，我得去砍掉他的头，因为他逃跑了。他想让他的儿子们，甚至他最小的布兰也去。凯特琳就像，他才10岁。
I have for later a little bit that would piggyback off of that for the costume department. Oh, okay. Well, we're gonna learn about the deserter. Lord Stark is notified about it, so he's like, all right, I gotta go chop his head off for deserting. And he wants his sons, even his youngest, Bran to go. And Caitlin's like, he's 10.
他才10岁，他不需要目睹这个。奈德就像，他不会永远是个男孩。而且凛冬将至。不是真正的寒冬，只是坏事。是的，他需要做好准备。我确实想指出我们有一个超级无敌的对视。凯特琳会盯着琼恩·雪诺看。我看到了。
He's 10, he doesn't need to witness this. And Ned's like, he won't be a boy forever. And winter is coming. Not actual cold winter, just bad stuff. Yep, and he needs to be ready. I do wanna point out we have a super-kadooper stare down. Caitlin is going to peer over at Jon Snow. I saw it.
是的，她做了我称之为“鼻翼扩张瞪视”的动作。是的。她对着他扩张鼻孔。她不喜欢他。不喜欢他。一点也不。好的，所以我们要去山里，有一个小地方你可以被斩首。
Yeah, she does what I'm calling the quote, nose flare glare. Yeah. She flares her nose at him. She doesn't like him. Doesn't like him. At all. All right, so we're going to be out in just the hills, and there's a little spot where you can get beheaded.
这显然是他们的斩首点。就像一棵树，上面有一个凹槽。我们有我们的第一个长名头衔演讲。那是经典的《权力的游戏》时刻。是的，我知道你喜欢它们。我喜欢它们，所以我来背诵它。好的。史塔克公爵，当他准备挥剑时，说，以拜拉席恩家族的劳勃之名，
This is clearly their beheading spot. It's like a tree that's got a divot in it. We have our very first long-name title speech. That's a classic Game of Thrones moment. Yeah, I know you love them. I love them, so I'm going to recite it. Okay. Lord Stark, as he's about to swing the sword, says, in the name of Robert of the House Baratheon,
他的名字的第一位，安达尔人和先民的国王，七大王国之主和全境守护，我，史塔克家族的艾德，临冬城公爵和北境守护，判处你死刑。是的。那有很多你必须学习的东西。那有很多，你必须把它弄对。作为一个演员，我认为这和医学术语一样难。
first of his name, King of the Andals and the First Men, Lord of the Seven Kingdoms and Protector of the Realm, I, Eddard of the House Stark, Lord of Winterfell, and Warden of the North, sentence you to die. Yeah. That's a lot you have to learn. That's a lot of, you gotta get that right. As an actor, that's as hard as medical jargon, I think.
也只是作为史塔克公爵。是的。就像如果他在斩首逃兵之前搞砸了呢？那会有点尴尬。真的会。他多久必须说一次？我不知道。
Also just as Lord Stark. Yeah. Like what if he fumbled that right before? He beheaded the deserter? That would be kind of a womp womp. It really would. How often does he have to say that? I don't know.
他必须在每次会议开始时都说吗？我知道。那是一大段话。确实。好吧，他做了。是的。他砍掉了那个人的头。是的。布兰看着它。10岁的小孩。是的。他看到了。我在这一点上有疑问，比如他们怎么处理那个人的身体和头？他们走了这么远来斩首。嗯哼。他们怎么
Does he have to open every meeting with that? I know. That's a mouthful. It is. Well, he does it. Yeah. He cuts off the guy's head. Yeah. And Bran watches it. Little 10 year old. Yeah. He sees it. I had questions at this point like what do they do with the guy's body and the guy's head? They've come so far to do the beheading. Mm-hmm. How do they
处理身体？树桩的东西，他们到那里时看起来很干净。那是某人的工作吗？它有一些红色，它没有——我不会陷入细节。我确实有一刻好奇。这就是我所说的。我喜欢你的大脑去的地方。这很像家务清单。
dispose of the body? The tree stump thing, it looked clean when they got there. Is that someone's job? It had some red, it didn't have- I'm not gonna get in the weeds about it. I did have a moment of curiosity. That's all I'm saying. I like where your brain goes. It's very sort of like chores list.
谁的家务？是的，谁现在必须处理那个被砍碎的人？嗯——因为有人必须处理。有人必须处理，我告诉你，如果他们聪明，他们会烧掉他们。剧透！哦。这个人？
Who's chores? Yeah, who has to now deal with the chopped up guy? Well- Because someone does. Someone does and I'm telling you right now, if they're smart, they'd burn them. Spoiler! Oh. This guy?
这个人刚刚被斩首，威尔？所有死人都应该被烧掉。哦。萨姆。哦。他们应该吗？所有的死者都应该被烧掉。这是真的。
This guy that was just beheaded, Will? All dead people should be burned. Oh. Sam. Oh. They should? All of the dead should be burned. It's true.
刚才被斩首的那个人，威尔？所有死人都应该被烧掉。噢。山姆。噢。是吗？所有死人都应该被烧掉。这是真的。
Oh. All of them. All of them. Okay. Anyway. Well, they're making their way back to Winterfell, It's true. Oh. All of them. All of them. Okay. Anyway. Well, they're making their way back to Winterfell and they come across a giant dead animal. I'll have you know that animal, that stag, I guess.
哦。所有的。所有的。好吧。总之。嗯，他们正在回临冬城的路上，这是真的。哦。所有的。所有的。好吧。总之。嗯，他们正在回临冬城的路上，然后他们遇到了一只死掉的巨型动物。我得告诉你，那只动物，那头雄鹿，我想是吧。
It was real. It was not a fakey dead animal. It had been dead for about two days and it was decomposing and they talk, all the actors talk about it was really smelly. You know what? What? You know, I read the dad to all the Lannisters, Tywin Lannister. I don't know.
它是真的。它不是那种假死动物。它已经死了大约两天了，正在腐烂，他们谈论，所有的演员都谈论它真的很臭。你知道吗？什么？你知道，我读过兰尼斯特家族所有人的父亲，泰温·兰尼斯特。我不知道。
Is he in this episode? He's not. But I read that he had to gut a deer, like prep a deer for an episode. In a scene? He really did it. They gave him a dead deer that he won, practiced on, and then won, he did it.
他在这集里吗？他不在。但我读到他必须给一只鹿开膛破肚，就像为一集节目准备一只鹿一样。在场景里？他真的做了。他们给了他一只他赢来的死鹿，练习了一下，然后赢了，他做到了。
Why? Unnecessary. You know what I just saw on Instagram that I was like, oh my god, we have to ask for this? You know how we always talk about like, when you have to eat steak or something like that in a scene? And it just fills you up. And it's like hard to do take after take
为什么？没必要。你知道我刚才在Instagram上看到了什么，当时我就想，天哪，我们必须要求这个吗？你知道我们总是谈论，当你在场景中必须吃牛排或类似的东西时？它会让你吃饱。而且拍了一遍又一遍很难做到
after take of eating steak. But like, what if there was a scene where you had to eat steak? This prop guy figured out a way to make a big hunk of watermelon look like a steak by putting on like, like a... Balsamic or something? Like smoky, yeah like a, I can't remember what he used, I think he used like liquid smoke on top of it and then he like painted it with a little bit of like edible food coloring that was brown. It looked like a steak. And then when you cut into it, the inside,
一遍又一遍地吃牛排。但是，如果有一个场景你必须吃牛排呢？这个道具师想出了一种方法，把一大块西瓜看起来像牛排，通过涂上像……香醋之类的东西？就像烟熏味，是的，就像一个，我不记得他用了什么，我想他用了像液体烟熏液涂在上面，然后他用一点点棕色的食用色素涂抹它。它看起来像牛排。然后当你切开它时，里面，
it just looked really rare. I was like, oh my God, that's genius. And I bet that guy could have made a real convincing fake deer. Yeah. You know? Probably. Yeah.
它看起来真的很生。我就想，天哪，真是天才。我敢打赌那个人本可以做出一个非常逼真的假鹿。是啊。你知道吗？可能吧。是啊。
It's a lot of watermelon. I'm not saying he made it on watermelon. I'm just saying, like, if you can make a piece of watermelon look like steak, you can make a fakie deer to cut up. Okay. Anyway, we do see, though, now also a dead wolf, and it's got an antler, like, through its neck. A dire wolf, I'm told. So the dire wolf and the deer, they kind of tussled. I guess so. And neither of them made it, but what we find are six little pups. Ned wants to have them killed.
那是很多西瓜。我不是说他是用西瓜做的。我只是说，如果你能让一块西瓜看起来像牛排，你就能做出一个假鹿来切开。好吧。总之，我们确实看到了，现在还有一只死狼，它的脖子上插着一只鹿角。有人告诉我是一只冰原狼。所以冰原狼和鹿，它们打了一架。我想是吧。它们都没活下来，但我们发现的是六只小幼崽。奈德想把它们杀了。
Ned's like, kill them. Ned's like, hey, they're not going to survive without their mother. And then Bran really wants one. And Jon Snow was like, you know what? They're the symbol of your house. You know? And they were here for a reason, and there's five of them, one for each of your children. They should each have one.
奈德说，杀了它们。奈德说，嘿，没有母亲它们活不下去。然后布兰真的很想要一只。而琼恩·雪诺说，你知道吗？它们是你家族的象征。你知道吗？它们出现在这里是有原因的，而且有五只，你的每个孩子一只。他们每人都应该有一只。
And then Ned gives a very dad speech where he's like, you will clean up after it. You will take care of it. If it dies, you will bury it. Oh, I wrote it down. What I wrote down was, has anyone written Ned Stark's book of parenting? Like is there a parody book?
然后奈德发表了一段非常父亲式的演讲，他说，你会清理它的排泄物。你会照顾它。如果它死了，你会埋葬它。哦，我记下来了。我写下的是，有人写过奈德·史塔克的育儿书吗？就像有一本恶搞书吗？
Because so far he has laid down the following wisdom. The man who passes the sentence should swing the sword. You will train them yourselves. You will feed them yourselves. If they die, you will bury them yourselves. I have a feeling like there's got to be like some stocking stuffer Ned Stark book of parenting. Yeah. I also like when he says a madman sees what a madman sees. That's just kind of like,
因为到目前为止，他已经提出了以下智慧。执行死刑的人应该挥剑。你们要自己训练它们。你们要自己喂养它们。如果它们死了，你们要自己埋葬它们。我有一种感觉，就像有一本奈德·史塔克的育儿书可以作为圣诞袜里的礼物。是啊。我也喜欢他说疯子看到疯子所看到的东西。那就像是，
look, it is what it is. Yeah. What are you going to do? Yeah. Yeah. That's right. I mean. Yeah. No, I like it. Well, there is an extra pup. At first, we only see five, but there is a sixth one. It's the runt. And Jon Snow is gonna get the runt. Yeah, because he's not a real stark. We're
看，事实就是这样。是啊。你要怎么办？是啊。是啊。没错。我是说。是啊。不，我喜欢它。嗯，还有一只多余的幼崽。起初，我们只看到五只，但还有第六只。它是最弱小的那只。而琼恩·雪诺要得到那只弱小的。是啊，因为他不是真正的史塔克。我们
learning he's not a stark. Yeah. Not a full, full-fledged stark. I do have a costume fun fact. Oh, what is it? This is from a great article on MentalFloss.com. You might have noticed in these wintery scenes, these guys are all wearing these gigantic coats, right? Yeah. Well, Game of Thrones owns much of the credit for its characters' iconic looks to costume designer Michelle Clapton.
了解到他不是史塔克。是啊。不是一个完全成熟的史塔克。我确实有一个服装趣闻。哦，是什么？这来自MentalFloss.com上的一篇很棒的文章。你可能已经注意到在这些冬天的场景中，这些人全都穿着这些巨大的外套，对吧？是啊。嗯，《权力的游戏》的大部分功劳归功于服装设计师米歇尔·克莱普顿，因为角色们的标志性造型。
And she would oversee a team of anywhere from 70 to 100 customers each season, because they had to have all of these costumes for so many actors. Wow. But... And they're not like shopping for those either. That's like, you're creating this.
而且她每季都要监督一个由70到100名服装师组成的团队，因为他们必须为这么多演员准备所有这些服装。哇。但是……而且他们也不是去买那些东西。那是，你是创造这个。
Creating. Sewing. So listen to this. What? This is so creative. Clapton revealed that several of the show's luxurious looking capes and coats were made from IKEA rugs.
创造。缝纫。所以听听这个。什么？这太有创意了。克莱普顿透露，剧中几件看起来很奢华的斗篷和外套是用宜家地毯做的。
She said, we'd take anything we can, we'd cut, we'd shave them, then we'd add like a strong leather strap. And following the share of hers, IKEA created a set of instructions for how to turn one of their rugs into a cape. That is brilliant. It is, right? I love it so much.
她说，我们会拿任何我们能拿到的东西，我们会剪裁，我们会刮掉它们，然后我们会加上像强力皮带之类的东西。在分享了她的故事后，宜家制作了一套说明书，教人们如何把他们的地毯变成斗篷。这太聪明了。是啊，对吧？我太喜欢了。
I have a wolf pup, fun fact. Oh yeah? Okay, so you know each of the Stark kids are going to get a wolf, and Sansa names her wolf Lady. I know. Lady was played by a pup named Zuni from Malik Northern Inuit Dogs. Sophie Turner, who plays Sansa, adopted Lady as her own pet when the first season wrapped.
我有一个关于狼崽的趣闻。哦，是吗？好吧，你知道每个史塔克孩子都会得到一只狼，珊莎给她的狼取名叫淑女。我知道。淑女是由一只名叫祖尼的幼崽扮演的，来自马利克北方因纽特犬。饰演珊莎的索菲·特纳在第一季结束时收养了淑女作为她自己的宠物。
I know, I thought that was so cool. You already knew that. Everybody already knew that. No, it's not. It's not, listen, I was just a fan of the show. So I was like. Everyone knows Sophie Turner has her wolf. Not everybody.
我知道，我觉得那太酷了。你已经知道了。每个人都已经知道了。不，不是。不是，听着，我只是这个节目的粉丝。所以我当时就想。每个人都知道索菲·特纳有她的狼。不是每个人。
Everyone does. No, they don't. Sam, did you know that? I did not know that. Hey! There you go. Well, I guess after season one, Hey! Boom. There you go. Well, I guess after season one, all live animals were replaced by CGI.
每个人都知道。不，他们不知道。萨姆，你知道吗？我不知道。嘿！给你。好吧，我想在第一季之后，嘿！砰。给你。好吧，我想在第一季之后，所有活体动物都被CGI取代了。
And I guess dead animals were replaced by real dead animals, per your fun fact about the deer. Yeah. But live animals became CGI after season one. That's good. I can take us into this next thing because we're now at King's Landing. That's the land I was trying to think of earlier, capital of the Seven Kingdoms.
我想死去的动物被真正的死动物取代了，根据你关于鹿的趣闻。是啊。但活体动物在第一季之后变成了CGI。那很好。我可以带我们进入下一件事，因为我们现在在君临。那是我刚才试图想到的地方，七大王国的首都。
And John Aaron, the previous Hand of the King, has died, Hand of the King. It was very clear to me it's the King's sidekick. Kind of sounds like the person who does all the work while the King is like drinking and having fun. Yes, it's his like counselor person. Yeah, we see a shot of John Aaron and he's dead, and he has rocks on his eyes,
而琼恩·艾林，前任国王之手，已经去世了，国王之手。对我来说很清楚，这是国王的副手。听起来像是那个做所有工作，而国王却在喝酒玩乐的人。是的，他是他的顾问之类的人。是啊，我们看到了琼恩·艾林的镜头，他死了，他的眼睛上有石头，
and the rocks have eyes painted on them. I became curious. counselor person. Yeah. We see a shot of John Aaron and he's dead and he has rocks on his eyes and the rocks have eyes painted on them. Yeah. I became curious. I know this show is made up but it seems to be a type of medieval alternate reality. I wondered if this was based on anything. Well, I know in like old Westerns
石头上画着眼睛。我变得好奇了。顾问之类的人。是啊。我们看到了琼恩·艾林的镜头，他死了，他的眼睛上有石头，石头上画着眼睛。是啊。我变得好奇了。我知道这个节目是虚构的，但它似乎是一种中世纪的替代现实。我想知道这是否基于任何东西。嗯，我知道在像老西部片里
they would put coins on the people's eyes. Yeah. Do you know why? So the eyelids don't roll back and open? Yes. I guess your eyeballs, like, deflate. Yeah. And then your eyelids can pop open,
他们会把硬币放在人们的眼睛上。是啊。你知道为什么吗？为了让眼睑不会向后翻开？是的。我猜你的眼球，就像，萎缩了。是啊。然后你的眼睑可能会弹开，
so you can put a coin or a stone on the eyelid to keep them closed so it doesn't freak people out. Yeah. Are they sew them shut for, like, weeks? Well, nowadays, they put, like, fakie eyeballs in. So their eyes are open? No, no, no. So they stay shut. It's like I believe a fakey eyeball. That's what it said.
所以你可以放一枚硬币或一块石头在眼睑上保持它们闭合，这样就不会吓到人。是啊。他们把它们缝起来，比如，几周？嗯，现在，他们放，比如，假眼球进去。所以他们的眼睛是睁着的？不，不，不。所以它们保持闭合。就像我相信一个假眼球。这就是它说的。
Modern undertakers put fake eyeballs in place. It makes the facial contours look correct, per the website I read. Wow. Well now we're going to meet Jamie and Cersei Lannister. They're the twins. The minute I saw these two, I knew they were going to hook up. And then as soon as I heard they were brother and sister, I was even more sure they were going to hook up. Like I just knew it. We should say the Lannisters have a very distinctive
现代殡仪员把假眼球放进去。根据我读的网站，这让面部轮廓看起来正确。哇。好吧，现在我们要见詹姆和瑟曦·兰尼斯特。他们是双胞胎。我看到这两个人的那一刻，我就知道他们会搞在一起。然后当我听说他们是兄妹时，我更加确定他们会搞在一起。就像我就是知道。我们应该说兰尼斯特家族有一个非常独特的
look. They're all very blonde, very blue eyed, and the Starks kind of all have brown hair. You know, there are these patterns in how these different groups look. Oh, yeah. Well, the Hottie brother and sister, they're both super good-looking as well. They're gonna talk about the death of John Aaron. Mm-hmm. Cersei thinks Jaime should be Hand of the King. Yeah, but he does not want that responsibility.
外表。他们都很金发，蓝眼睛，而史塔克家族的人大多有棕色头发。你知道，这些不同群体的外表是有规律的。哦，是啊。嗯，那个火辣的兄妹，他们也都超级好看。他们要谈论琼恩·艾林的死。嗯哼。瑟曦认为詹姆应该是国王之手。是啊，但他不想要那个责任。
Their days are too long and their lives are too short, Angela. I know. That's some foreshadowing. But you know what? He says he doesn't want the job, days are too long and their lives are too short, Angela. I know, that's some foreshadowing. But you know what? He says he doesn't want the job, but then later he's gonna like get in this pissing contest with Ned Stark, who I mean is gonna get offered the job and now he's like his feathers are ruffled,
他们的日子太长，生命太短，安吉拉。我知道。那是一些伏笔。但你知道吗？他说他不想要这份工作，日子太长，生命太短，安吉拉。我知道，那是一些伏笔。但你知道吗？他说他不想要这份工作，但后来他要和奈德·史塔克进行这种意气之争，我的意思是，他会被提供这份工作，现在他就像他的羽毛被弄乱了，
but you just said you don't want it. So like settle down, Jamie. Pick a lane. Right, what do you want? What do you want? Beside your sister. Well, now we're gonna see a raven Let's settle down, Jamie. Pick a lane. Right. What do you want? What do you want? Beside your sister. Well, now we're going to see a raven and it's flying towards Winterfell.
但你刚才说你不想要它。所以，冷静点，詹姆。选一条路。对，你想要什么？你想要什么？除了你的妹妹。嗯，现在我们要看到一只乌鸦，让我们冷静点，詹姆。选一条路。对。你想要什么？你想要什么？除了你的妹妹。嗯，我们要看到一只乌鸦，它正飞向临冬城。
It comes with a message. Caitlin Stark is going to make her way through this muddy courtyard to the very iconic Game of Thrones piece of scenery. Is it the tree with the red leaves? It's so pretty. I wrote it down. I said the production design is so pretty here. So it's a tree with the red leaves. It's so pretty. I wrote it down. I said the production design is so pretty here. So it's a tree with a white bark.
它带着一条信息。凯特琳·史塔克要穿过这个泥泞的庭院，来到那个非常标志性的《权力的游戏》风景。是那棵有红叶的树吗？它太漂亮了。我记下来了。我说这里的场景设计太漂亮了。所以它是一棵有红叶的树。它太漂亮了。我记下来了。我说这里的场景设计太漂亮了。所以它是一棵有白色树皮的树。
It's got these very red leaves, red sap. It's often found in the God's Woods is what it's called. That's the forested area within the castle walls. And many of these trees have faces carved into their trunks and they're considered sacred by the followers of the old gods. OK, well, it's beautiful. I was very impressed. So are you telling me that, like,
它有这些非常红的叶子，红色的树液。它通常出现在所谓的神木林中。那是城堡墙内森林覆盖的区域。这些树中的许多树干上刻着脸，被旧神的信徒视为神圣。好的，嗯，它很美。我印象非常深刻。所以你是告诉我，就像，
many important conversations are going to happen at this tree or trees like it? Yes. Yes. OK. They're sacred, and they kind of, in some ways, are like all knowing. Well, this is where Caitlyn is gonna tell Ned
许多重要的谈话会发生在这棵树或类似的树上吗？是的。是的。好的。它们是神圣的，它们在某种程度上，就像无所不知。嗯，这就是凯特琳要告诉奈德
about the Hand of the King dying. And this guy was like a father to Ned. We're gonna learn. He is crushed. She also says, you know what's coming next. The Raven had more news. Mm-hmm. The King and Queen and their whole entourage are on their way to Winterfell.
关于国王之手去世的事。而这个人对奈德来说就像父亲一样。我们要了解到。他崩溃了。她还说，你知道接下来会发生什么。乌鸦还有更多消息。嗯哼。国王和王后以及他们的整个随从正在前往临冬城的路上。
You know what that means. They are gonna want you to be the next hand. Caitlin's like, you can always say no. She really wants him to say no. Oh, she's gonna make that clear. Now we're inside the Winterfell castle. There's lots and lots of hubbub because they're getting ready to host.
你知道那意味着什么。他们会想要你成为下一任国王之手。凯特琳说，你总是可以拒绝。她真的希望他拒绝。哦，她会把这一点说清楚。现在我们在临冬城城堡里面。有很多很多的喧闹，因为他们正准备接待。
The king is coming. Yeah, there's food prep in the great hall. And we learned that Lord Tyrion's chamber is gonna need a lot of candles because he likes to stay up late reading. And Master Lewin says, I heard he drinks all night. Yes, this is the other sibling to the Hathi brother and sister who are getting it on.
国王要来了。是啊，大厅里有食物准备。我们了解到提利昂大人的房间需要很多蜡烛，因为他喜欢熬夜看书。而鲁温学士说，我听说他整晚都在喝酒。是的，这是那个正在搞在一起的火辣兄妹的另一个兄弟。
Yeah, and Caitlin says, how much could he possibly drink? A man of his stature. Which is foreshadowing. Foreshadowing. Well, also now the Stark boys are gonna get shaves and haircuts in preparation. So prerequisite for this scene is everyone had to be shirtless. Yes, I noticed. Everybody has their shirt off. Calm down HBO. Don't get me started. I know. On
是啊，凯特琳说，他到底能喝多少？以他的身材。这是伏笔。伏笔。嗯，还有现在史塔克家的男孩们要剃须和理发作为准备。所以这个场景的前提是每个人都必须赤裸上身。是的，我注意到了。每个人都脱掉了衬衫。冷静点，HBO。别让我开始。我知道。关于
the number of breasts we're gonna see in this. Lots of boobs. Episode. It's literally the Benny Hill of drama. So many boobs. But yes. I just love the Benny Hill reference. I mean, that's what I thought of. I was like, what is this? Remember that? Of course I remember.
我们将要看到的乳房数量。很多胸部。这一集。这简直是戏剧界的本尼·希尔。这么多胸部。但是是的。我只是喜欢本尼·希尔的引用。我是说，那就是我所想的。我就想，这是什么？记得那个吗？我当然记得。
We all remember it from our childhood. It was a comedy show, but there was lots of boobs. It was on TV. It was a BBC show. It was a comedy sketch show. And then just topless women. I know. Okay, the boys obviously didn't need to like
我们都从童年时代记得它。那是一个喜剧节目，但有很多胸部。它在电视上。那是一个BBC节目。那是一个喜剧小品节目。然后就是上身赤裸的女性。我知道。好吧，男孩们显然不需要像
shower or anything before their haircuts cause they also are kind of like sweaty and dirty and shirtless. I noticed the writers think that this shaving scene is quote the worst scene we've ever written and probably the most embarrassing. That includes the pilot before the pilot. Well, they said that the only reason it was there was because there were a few snippets
在理发前洗澡什么的，因为他们也都有点汗流浃背、脏兮兮的，而且赤裸上身。我注意到编剧们认为这个剃须场景是“我们写过的最糟糕的场景，可能也是最尴尬的”。这包括试播集之前的试播集。嗯，他们说它之所以在那里，唯一的原因是因为有几个片段
that they did use from the original show and their beards weren't going to match. So this was designed to create continuity between like their shaggy beards before and then their like non-shaggy beards after. Oh, this was like a forced scene. It was. And HBO was like, make them topless. I guess so. So.
他们确实使用了来自原始节目的片段，而他们的胡子不匹配。所以这是为了在他们之前的蓬乱胡子和之后的不蓬乱胡子之间建立连续性。哦，这就像一个被迫的场景。确实是。而HBO就像，让他们赤裸上身。我想是吧。所以。
Yes. Well, everyone is sort of like watching the entourage of the King and Queen make its way. Bran has scaled up the castle walls. He's watching. I mean, this kid can climb. Oh yeah. He's like way up high. And his mom catches him and is like, hey, no more climbing. Foreshadowing. At 25 minutes, 35 seconds, as everyone is riding in with their red flags and the lion symbol, that's the symbol of the Lannisters, we see Prince Joffrey for the first time. and one of my favorite characters from the series, the Hound.
是的。嗯，每个人都在某种程度上看着国王和王后的随从前进。布兰爬上了城堡墙。他在看。我是说，这孩子会爬。哦，是啊。他爬得很高。他妈妈抓住了他，就像，嘿，别再爬了。伏笔。在25分35秒，当每个人都带着他们的红旗和狮子标志骑马进来时，那是兰尼斯特家族的标志，我们第一次看到了乔佛里王子。还有我最喜欢的系列角色之一，猎狗。
What's the Hound? The Hound is the younger brother of Ser Gregor, aka the Mountain. The Hound is the personal guard of Prince Joffrey. The Mountain protects the Queen. Anyway, they're not really featured in this episode, but Lady is someone, is a fan of the series. Uh-huh.
什么是猎狗？猎狗是格雷果·克里冈爵士的弟弟，也就是魔山。猎狗是乔佛里王子的私人卫兵。魔山保护王后。总之，他们在这集中并没有真正出现，但淑女是某人，是该系列的粉丝。嗯哼。
This is the Hound. You're seeing the Hound. And then when the Stark family lines up, 25 minutes, 58 seconds, for the first time ever, and he doesn't have a single word in this episode, and you only see him here, it's Hodor. Oh, Hodor, I wondered when we were gonna see Hodor. Hodor's right there. I have a spoiler about this moment.
这就是猎狗。你正在看到猎狗。然后当史塔克家族排成一行时，25分58秒，第一次，他在这一集中没有说一句话，而且你只在这里看到他，那是阿多。哦，阿多，我一直在想我们什么时候会看到阿多。阿多就在那里。我有一个关于这个时刻的剧透。
Because what's gonna happen is the king is gonna arrive. He comes in sort of last. He gets off his horse. He walks over to Ned. He's like, you've gotten fat. And then Ned kind of looks at him like, oh, someone else. And they laugh and they hug and, oh, look, they're old friends. And then the king goes and he, like, oh, it's someone else. And they laugh and they hug and, oh, look, they're old friends.
因为接下来会发生的是国王要到了。他算是最后进来的。他从马上下来。他走到奈德身边。他说，你变胖了。然后奈德看着他就像，哦，其他人。他们笑了起来，拥抱在一起，哦，看，他们是老朋友。然后国王走过去，他，就像，哦，是其他人。他们笑了起来，拥抱在一起，哦，看，他们是老朋友。
And then the king goes and he, like, greets all the Starks. Here's the thing. I guess that when Robert greets the Starks, he hugs Ned, he hugs Caitlin, he ruffles Rickon's hair, and he shakes hands with Rob. He does not touch Bran, Sansa, Arya, or Jon Stark. Here's the thing. All four of the Starks that Robert makes physical contact
然后国王走过去，他，就像，问候所有的史塔克。事情是这样的。我猜当劳勃问候史塔克时，他拥抱了奈德，他拥抱了凯特琳，他揉了揉瑞肯的头发，他与罗柏握手。他没有碰布兰、珊莎、艾莉亚或琼恩·史塔克。事情是这样的。劳勃有身体接触的所有四个史塔克
with die violently in future seasons. And the four that he doesn't touch survive. This strange coincidence became a popular theory that Robert has the touch of death. Oh, Sam, what do you think of that coincidence? Jenna, I need you to watch every episode. I need this to continue for years. What is it that you need to continue?
在未来的几季中都死得很惨。而他没有碰的那四个幸存了下来。这个奇怪的巧合变成了一个流行的理论，即劳勃有死亡之触。哦，萨姆，你觉得那个巧合怎么样？詹娜，我需要你观看每一集。我需要这持续几年。你需要什么持续？
There's just so many horrible, heinous things coming up. I'm, like, replaying all the things. Yes. Yeah. Wow. Like, she doesn't even know about Reek yet. No. Poor Reek.
接下来有太多可怕、令人发指的事情了。我，就像，在重温所有的事情。是的。是啊。哇。就像，她甚至还不知道臭佬。不。可怜的臭佬。
Poor Reek. OK. Well, I know Jon Snow dies, and I know he gets revived. I know because there were like articles about it where people were freaking out. F***ing pissed off. Yeah. Well, now pretty quickly, King Robert is going to say to Lord Stark, I want, you know, take me to your crypt. I need to pay my respects. Cersei is like, hey, we've been writing for a month, my love.
可怜的臭佬。好的。嗯，我知道琼恩·雪诺死了，我知道他复活了。我知道，因为有关于它的文章，人们都疯了。他妈的生气。是啊。嗯，现在很快，劳勃国王要对史塔克大人说，我想要，你知道，带我去你的地窖。我需要表达我的敬意。瑟曦就像，嘿，我们已经骑了一个月了，我的爱人。
Surely the dead can wait. Robert's like, nope." Cersei is like, "'Hey, we've been writing for a month, my love. Surely the dead can wait.'" Robert's like, "'Nope, Cersei is pissed. She's embarrassed. She's not happy.'" Well, we're gonna find out why. Yeah. I thought he wanted to pay his respects
死人肯定可以等。劳勃就像，“不。”瑟曦就像，“嘿，我们已经骑了一个月了，我的爱人。死人肯定可以等。”劳勃就像，“不，瑟曦很生气。她很尴尬。她不高兴。”嗯，我们要找出原因。是啊。我以为他想表达他的敬意
to like the men who had fallen in his service. No. No. It's always about a woman. Yeah. He had the hots for Ned Stark's sister who's buried down below. But wait, first, I need to go back to Queen Cersei getting out of the chariot.
给那些为他服务而牺牲的人。不。不。总是关于一个女人。是啊。他迷恋奈德·史塔克的妹妹，她被埋在下面。但等等，首先，我需要回到瑟曦王后下马车。
Because all I could think about was, oh my god, I would be so queasy. And she is so sour. She looks like she could throw up, truly. And it's no doubt that she is so cranky. But also, did you know that Lena Headley was pregnant while filming this episode? No.
因为我能想到的只有，天哪，我会感到非常恶心。而且她那么酸。她看起来好像要吐了，真的。毫无疑问她那么暴躁。但还有，你知道琳娜·海蒂在拍摄这一集时怀孕了吗？不知道。
Yes. And so that's why in so many of her scenes, she's either like wrapped in furs or like sitting down or like the opening. She's totally you in Dinner Party. Like in the opening scene when she's like, hello, brother, she's like leaning forward. And that was so like her robe would like cover up her belly.
是的。所以这就是为什么在她的许多场景中，她要么被皮草包裹，要么坐着，或者像开场。她完全是你《晚宴》里的样子。就像在开场场景中，当她说，你好，兄弟，她就像向前倾。那就像她的长袍会遮住她的肚子。
And then at the end, when they're getting it on, originally she was gonna be naked. She couldn't be naked because she was so obviously pregnant. So they had her clothed. And then I guess that started the trend where whenever Cersei has sex, she's always clothed. She's like the one person we don't see nude
然后在最后，当他们搞在一起时，最初她本应该是裸体的。她不能裸体，因为她明显怀孕了。所以他们让她穿上了衣服。然后我猜这开启了一个趋势，每当瑟曦发生性关系时，她总是穿着衣服。她就像我们在系列中看不到裸体的唯一一个人
in the series apparently. Also, I have to imagine, much like Paul Feig, Tim Van Patten had to sort of figure out how do we have a sex scene and not see the belly, which is what you had to do with Dwight. Yes. Where do we put him to block it all? Yes.
显然。另外，我必须想象，就像保罗·费格一样，蒂姆·范·帕顿必须想办法，我们怎么拍性爱场景而不看到肚子，这就是你对德怀特必须做的。是的。我们把他们放在哪里来遮挡这一切？是的。
Yeah. Okay, so now we're gonna go down to the crypt. Yes, and Robert is paying his respects to Ned's sister. He was clearly in love with her. Mm-hmm. He says to Ned, we were meant to rule together. If your sister had lived, we would have been bound by blood. And he's like, you know what, though? It's not too late.
是啊。好的，所以现在我们要下到地窖。是的，劳勃正在向奈德的妹妹表达敬意。他显然爱着她。嗯哼。他对奈德说，我们注定要一起统治。如果你的妹妹还活着，我们就会有血缘关系。他说，你知道吗，不过？还不算太晚。
I have a son, you have a daughter. Let's join our houses. This is also when he says, I want you to be the new Hand of the King. Yes. Like, he just says it. And I mean, how want you to be the new hand of the king. Yes. Like he just says it. And I mean, how can you say no to that? This guy just rode for 30 days to personally ask you. He came with his whole family.
我有一个儿子，你有一个女儿。让我们联姻吧。这也是他说，我想要你成为新的国王之手的时候。是的。就像，他只是说了出来。而且我的意思是，怎么能拒绝那个？这个人刚刚骑了30天来亲自问你。他带着他的全家来了。
Yeah. I mean, this is a lot of pressure. And he says, I need you. They're old friends. Yes, they're old friends. Did you think that these two guys looked slightly different in the scene compared to the rest of the episode? Tell me why.
是啊。我的意思是，这压力很大。他说，我需要你。他们是老朋友。是的，他们是老朋友。你觉得这两个人在这个场景中看起来和这一集的其余部分略有不同吗？告诉我为什么。
This is one of two full scenes that were left over from the original pilot. It was also shot on film, so it looks a little different. OK. And the next scene coming up, this is the other scene that survived from the original pilot. Well, it's Tyrion Lannister and he's, you know, he's with a lady and getting serviced by the lady.
这是从原始试播集中留下的两个完整场景之一。它也是用胶片拍摄的，所以看起来有点不同。好的。而接下来的场景，这是从原始试播集中幸存下来的另一个场景。嗯，是提利昂·兰尼斯特，他，你知道，他和一位女士在一起，并接受那位女士的服务。
He is. And Jamie bursts in and says, look, our sister is requesting your attention. All right, this is when I got real interested in everyone's hair. This scene? Yeah, when I saw Peter Dink everyone's hair. This scene? Yeah. When I saw Peter Dinklage's hair.
他是。詹姆闯进来，说，看，我们的妹妹需要你的注意。好吧，这是我真正对每个人的头发感兴趣的时候。这个场景？是啊，当我看到彼得·丁克每个人的头发。这个场景？是啊。当我看到彼得·丁克拉奇的头发。
Okay. His blonde hair. They have clearly dyed all of the actors' hair. Because Lena Headley as well was like kind of known for being a brunette. Right? Well, that's a wig. And now she's clearly wearing a wig. Yes.
好的。他的金发。他们显然染了所有演员的头发。因为琳娜·海蒂也因为是黑发而闻名。对吧？嗯，那是假发。现在她显然戴着假发。是的。
Yes. Because the Lannisters are blonde. So they tried to make Peter a blonde. Yes. I really felt like Peter Dinklage's hair in this scene had a hint of Ryan during Michael Scott Paper Company. It had a little hint of early 90s, sun in by the swimming pool.
是的。因为兰尼斯特家族是金发。所以他们试图让彼得成为金发。是的。我真的觉得彼得·丁克拉奇在这个场景中的头发有一点瑞安在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司时的感觉。它有一点90年代初，游泳池边晒太阳的感觉。
Yes. I guess, like I said, this scene was from the original pilot, and this was their first take on his hair. I guess in the book, Tyrion's hair is described as so blonde it seemed white. This is a wig. Oh. So for the pilot it seemed white. This is a wig. Oh. So for the pilot, Peter Dinklage wore a wig,
是的。我猜，就像我说的，这个场景来自原始试播集，这是他们对他头发的第一次尝试。我猜在书中，提利昂的头发被描述为金得看起来像白色。这是假发。哦。所以对于试播集，彼得·丁克拉奇戴了假发，
but by the final version, they changed it to look more natural. And you can see his hair change throughout the pilot. You can tell when it was wig and when it was different. Wig, no wig. Speaking of hair, because they became so obsessed, Joffrey also had a different haircut in the original pilot. It was more of a page boy cut. It was kind of like Henry VIII.
但在最终版本中，他们把它改得看起来更自然。你可以看到他的头发在整个试播集中发生变化。你可以分辨出什么时候是假发，什么时候是不同的。假发，没假发。说到头发，因为他们变得如此痴迷，乔佛里在原始试播集中也有不同的发型。那更像是一个侍童发型。它有点像亨利八世。
They decided that this more modern cut in the version that aired gave him a type of spitefulness without making him look so dorky. I see it. Yeah. And finally, before we leave this scene, I need to give an actor shout out to the woman who plays the sex worker with Tyrion.
他们决定，在播出的版本中，这种更现代的发型给了他一种刻薄，而不会让他看起来那么书呆子。我看到了。是啊。最后，在我们离开这个场景之前，我需要给扮演提利昂性工作者的女士一个演员致敬。
She was played by Esme Bianco, and she's gonna go on to be a recurring character. Mm-hmm. I remember her from the first time I watched the series because I thought she was so good. And I found this quote from her. She said, "'I was originally cast, and my name was the redheaded whore.
她由埃斯梅·比安科扮演，她将成为一个常驻角色。嗯哼。我从第一次看这个系列时就记得她，因为我觉得她太棒了。我找到了她的一句引语。她说，“我最初被选中，我的名字是红发妓女。
I didn't have a name at that point, and I was only meant to do this one scene. And they ended up loving her so much that she became a recurring character, and they named her Roz. She's in the series for a long time. I remember her. Yeah.
那时我没有名字，我本来只打算拍这一场戏。结果他们太喜欢她了，以至于她成为了一个常驻角色，他们给她取名叫萝丝。她在系列中待了很长时间。我记得她。是啊。
Well, basically, I guess Cersei wants Tyrion and Jaime to keep her company because they hate the Starks, and they don't want to sit through this long meal with them. And then Jaime, I guess, gets three more girls for Tyrion. I don't know what's happening here. He's like, I know you, we're going to get this all over at once. Yeah. So just have like four ladies at one time and then please come to dinner.
嗯，基本上，我猜瑟曦希望提利昂和詹姆陪伴她，因为他们讨厌史塔克家族，他们不想和他们坐在一起吃这顿漫长的饭。然后詹姆，我猜，又给提利昂找了三个女孩。我不知道这里发生了什么。他就像，我了解你，我们要一次性解决这个问题。是啊。所以一次找四个女士，然后请来吃晚饭。
And make it to dinner. Right. Well, we're back in the crypt now and Robert is just still talking about Ned's sister and just like saying, why did you have to bury her in a place like this? She needs to be on a hilltop somewhere with sun and clouds. And Robert says, you know, in my dreams, I kill him every night. Who's him? Who's he talking about? He kills who?
并且赶上晚饭。对。嗯，我们现在回到地窖，劳勃还在谈论奈德的妹妹，就像说，你为什么要像这样把她埋在这种地方？她需要在一个山顶上，有阳光和云彩。劳勃说，你知道，在我的梦里，我每天晚上都杀了他。他是谁？他在说谁？他杀了谁？
Is this who killed Ned's sister? Well, all of that. I can't answer any of this, Sam. I can't answer. Or you can. No, no, no. No, because you're gonna watch it. Because we're holding out hope.
这是杀了奈德妹妹的人吗？嗯，所有这些。我无法回答任何这些，萨姆。我无法回答。或者你可以。不，不，不。不，因为你会看的。因为我们抱着希望。
Here's the thing though. Okay. Ned says, it's done, your grace. The Targaryens are gone. And then Robert says, not all of them. Dun, dun, dun. And now we're gonna meet some. We're gonna go across the narrow sea to Pintos. Sure. We're gonna meet some. We're gonna go across the narrow sea to Pentos.
不过事情是这样的。好的。奈德说，完成了，陛下。坦格利安家族已经消失了。然后劳勃说，并非全部。当，当，当。现在我们要见一些。我们要穿过狭海去潘托斯。当然。我们要见一些。我们要穿过狭海去潘托斯。
Sure. We're gonna meet Daenerys. Why do you say it like that? Sure. Pentos. Just a made up place. This whole, have you never watched anything that is like written, like a movie? It's all fiction. Everything is made up.
当然。我们要见丹妮莉丝。你为什么那样说？当然。潘托斯。只是一个虚构的地方。这一切，你从来没看过像电影那样写的东西吗？这全是虚构的。一切都是虚构的。
Everything is made up. The office is made up. But it's set in a- Dunder Mifflin. Oh sure, that's a name, bleh. I know, but paper companies are real. Scranton, Pennsylvania is real. The jobs we're doing are actual jobs. There were kings and queens. I guess.
一切都是虚构的。《办公室》是虚构的。但它设定在一个——邓德·米夫林。哦当然，那是一个名字，呸。我知道，但造纸公司是真实的。斯克兰顿，宾夕法尼亚是真实的。我们做的工作是实际的工作。曾经有国王和王后。我想是吧。
Yes. It's just so many names to remember in places and lands and relationships. It's like, like the fact that I was watching this pilot and I was following along with an outline that Ainsley made for me. And I still was like, wait, who's that? Like I had a literal, like it was literally printed on a sheet of paper for me and I can't hold it in my brain.
是的。只是有太多的名字要记住，在地方、土地和关系中。就像，就像我正在看这个试播集，我跟着安斯利为我做的提纲。我仍然就像，等等，那是谁？就像我有一个字面上的，就像它字面上印在一张纸上给我，我无法把它记在脑子里。
This is learning a whole new world. Isn't that what happens when you read a book? Don't you learn a whole new world? Yeah, but she just watched Lord of the Rings, so I'm sure her tank is pretty full of names and places. She's tapped out. She's tapped out. Well, anyway, I have a little trivia about this scene. Okay, well, all of that is to say I was enjoying it.
这是学习一个全新的世界。读一本书时不是会发生这种情况吗？你不是学习一个全新的世界吗？是啊，但她刚看了《指环王》，所以我肯定她的名字和地方的储备已经满了。她精疲力竭了。她精疲力竭了。嗯，总之，我有一个关于这个场景的小花絮。好的，嗯，所有这些都是说我很享受。
I enjoy this pilot. I think it's a good show. Okay. Well, I do have a little bit of GOT trivia. Game of Thrones trivia, I'm keeping up. So apparently in the books, the Targaryens had silver hair and violet eyes. And during shooting, Daenerys and Viserys originally wore violet contact lenses. I read that.
我享受这个试播集。我觉得这是一个好节目。好的。嗯，我确实有一点《权力的游戏》花絮。权力的游戏花絮，我跟上了。所以显然在书中，坦格利安家族有银发和紫眼。在拍摄期间，丹妮莉丝和韦赛里斯最初戴着紫色隐形眼镜。我读过那个。
But the writers decided they impacted the actor's ability to portray emotion. So they were like, nope. I read that. But the writers decided they impacted the actor's ability to portray emotion. So they were like, nope. Smart. Here's what I am learning when I meet this guy. Viserius. Yep. So we've got another brother sister relationship
但编剧们决定它们影响了演员表现情感的能力。所以他们就像，不。我读过那个。但编剧们决定它们影响了演员表现情感的能力。所以他们就像，不。聪明。这就是我见到这个家伙时学到的。韦赛里斯。是的。所以我们有另一个兄妹关系
with weird sexual undertones. And more than that though, if you are a man with blonde hair in the Game of Thrones in that universe, your character is very likely to be a creeper. Almost all the blonde men are total creepers. Okay, I'll track it in my rewatch. Well, he's a super creeper.
带有奇怪的性暗示。而且不仅如此，如果你是一个在《权力的游戏》那个宇宙中拥有金发的男人，你的角色很有可能是一个变态。几乎所有的金发男人都是彻头彻尾的变态。好的，我会在重温时跟踪它。嗯，他是一个超级变态。
He needs her to be perfect because he's gonna be presenting her today to Khal Drago, who's very important in the Dothraki. He wants this union to go well because he wants his army so he can go and get his throne back, have a little foreshadowing. Daenerys is gonna get into a bathtub and they're like, no, no, no, it's too hot.
他需要她是完美的，因为他今天要向卓戈卡奥介绍她，他在多斯拉克人中非常重要。他希望这次联姻顺利，因为他想要他的军队，这样他就可以去夺回他的王位，有一点伏笔。丹妮莉丝要进入浴缸，他们就像，不，不，不，太热了。
She doesn't even feel a thing. She just gets right in. Yeah, I read that later she's gonna walk into fire or something. I don't know, she can be hot is what we know. Well, listen, in the next scene, we are gonna meet this Carl Drago person. Carl Drago.
她甚至感觉不到任何东西。她直接进去了。是啊，我读到后来她要走进火里什么的。我不知道，她可以很热，这是我们知道的。嗯，听着，在下一个场景中，我们要见这个卡奥·卓戈。卡奥·卓戈。
Carl Drago person. No, R. Sorry. Carl. Carl. I'll say it again. Carl. His name is not Carl.
卡奥·卓戈人。不，R。抱歉。卡奥。卡奥。我再说一遍。卡奥。他的名字不是卡奥。
I'm trying, I am really trying by the way. You are, you are. Carl Drogo. Carl Drogo. Khal Drogo? Yes, we're gonna meet him, but why don't we take a break and I will learn the names and then we will be back to finish breaking down Game of Thrones. ["Game of Thrones Theme"]
我正在尝试，顺便说一句，我真的很努力。你是，你是。卡奥·卓戈。卡奥·卓戈。卓戈卡奥？是的，我们要见他，但我们为什么不休息一下，我学会名字，然后我们回来完成对《权力的游戏》的解析。“权力的游戏主题曲”
We are back and Daenerys is waiting for Khal Drago. I guess Dothraki are notoriously late. They run a little behind. Who's this helper guy? Who's this guy who's like in his ear? The guy who he introduces the brother and sister to call. He just works for them. I don't know.
我们回来了，丹妮莉丝正在等卓戈卡奥。我猜多斯拉克人以迟到著称。他们有点落后。这个帮手是谁？这个在他耳边的人是谁？那个向卡奥介绍兄妹的人。他只是为他们工作。我不知道。
Okay. Well, I got an audio clip because Angela, he does the like, the name and the house thing and I know how much you like it. So let's listen. I think you really like it too. I'm starting to like it. I want to write my own for myself. May I present my honored guests, Viserys of House Targaryen, the third of his name, the rightful king of the Andals and the first men, and his sister Daenerys of
好的。嗯，我得到了一个音频剪辑，因为安吉拉，他做了那种名字和家族的事情，我知道你有多喜欢它。所以让我们听听。我想你真的很喜欢它。我开始喜欢它了。我想为自己写一个。请允许我介绍我的尊贵客人，坦格利安家族的韦赛里斯，他名字的第三位，安达尔人和先民的合法国王，以及他的妹妹坦格利安家族的丹妮莉丝。阿吉·阿纳哈尔·阿沙拉特。你看到她了吗？是啊，家族的事情。这是一件大事。我为你写了一个。你记得吗？我不记得！你写了？我写了，女士。我为你写了一个。你记得吗？我不记得。你写了？我写了，女士。
House Targaryen. Aji Anahar Ashalat. Do you see her? Yeah, the house thing. It's a big thing. I wrote one for you. Do you remember? I don't! You did? I did, lady. I wrote one for you. Do you remember? I don't. You did? I did, lady.
为你生日那年，我发在《办公室女士》播客上，我写了你的《权力的游戏》头衔版本。哦！费舍尔家族的詹娜，她名字的第一位，总结大师，快讯女王，琐事保护者，威浮球摄政女士，面包制造者，奶酪串联者，曲棍球妈妈指挥官，阳光猫守护者，以及播客之母。我喜欢它！
For your birthday one year, I posted on Office Ladies' Pod and I wrote my version of your Game of Thrones title. Oh! Jenna of House Fisher, the first of her name, the Summary Master, Queen of the Fast Facts, Protector of the Chucket, Lady Regent of Wiffle Ball, Maker of Bread, Stringer of Cheese, Commander of the Hockey Moms, Keeper of Sunny Cat, and Mother of Podcasting. I love it!
它太棒了。我也为自己写了一个。你写了？是的。那个在哪里？让我们看看。因为我走过我的房子，我捡起所有的杯子和碗。我是那种人。
It's so great. And I wrote one for myself. You did? Yes. Where's that one? Let's see. It's because I walk through my house and I pick up all the cups and bowls. I'm that person.
是的。我们有三个孩子。有杯子和碗以及各种各样的东西。我只是走。我很熟悉。我捡起它们。所以我让我女儿在这些差事之一时给我拍了一张照片。是的。
Yes. We have three kids. There's cups and bowls and all kinds of things. And I just walk. I am familiar. I pick them up. So I had my daughter take a picture of me on one of these errands. Yes.
捡起杯子和碗。然后我为自己写了这个。杂物家族的杯子金西，她名字的第一位，混乱守护者，被遗弃的碗和杯子的保护者，堆叠物品之母，以及只跑一趟就能取回所有东西的女王。这些太棒了，安。我是说，我喜欢它们。嗯，我不知道你是否知道这一点，
Of picking up cups and bowls. And then I wrote this for myself. Cups Kinsey of House Clutter, first of her name, keeper of the mess, protector of the bowls and cups left behind, mother of stacking items and queen of making only one trip to retrieve everything. These are great, Anne. I mean, I love them. Well, I don't know if you know this,
但Screen Rant对不同的办公室角色可能来自哪些家族进行了分析。哦，真的吗？是的。我不知道这个。所以我只挑选了那些基于刚看完试播集而有意义的，因为他们列出了很多家族
but Screen Rant did a breakdown of what houses different office characters might come from. Oh, really? Yes. I didn't know this. So I only pulled the ones that made sense based on having just watched the pilot because they listed a lot of houses
对我来说没有意义。但他们说吉姆·哈珀特和迈克尔·斯科特都是史塔克家族。你同意吗？吉姆·哈珀特，我是说。这是他们对吉姆的评价。他们说，“当然，有时吉姆会不时地偷懒，
that didn't make sense to me. But they said that both Jim Halpert and Michael Scott were House Stark. Do you agree with that? Jim Halpert, I mean. Here's what they said about Jim. They said, quote, Sure, sometimes Jim will goof off from time to time
并对他的同事进行精心策划的恶作剧，但在一天结束时，他是邓德·米夫林大多数人仰望的角色，他有一颗宽广的心，他会为他最爱的人做任何事。他会在路上犯一些错误，但他只是人类，就像史塔克家族的人一样。对于迈克尔，他们说，“他并不陌生于犯错和做出令人尴尬的错误，就像史塔克家族的角色一样。然而，像史塔克家族一样，每当情况危急时，
and pull elaborate pranks on his coworkers, but at the end of the day, he is the character that the majority of people at Dunder Mifflin look up to, he has a big heart, and he will do pretty much anything for the people he loves most. He'll make some mistakes along the way, but he's only human, just like the people of House Stark. And for Michael, they said, quote, he is no stranger to slipping up and making cringe-worthy mistakes, just like the characters in House Stark. Yet, like the Stark family, whenever the chips are down,
他们会立刻站起来。他们还说迈克尔·斯科特是该系列的灵魂，因此，他看起来很适合史塔克家族。嗯，他确实做了很多可能让他进入守夜人的恶作剧。我会这么说。哦，守夜人是一种惩罚？是啊，有一点。哦。我以为你，比如，自愿参加。我是说，琼恩。哦，守夜人是一种惩罚？是啊，有一点。哦，是啊。我以为
they get right back up. They also said Michael Scott is the heart and soul of the series, and for that reason, he seems like a good fit for House Stark. Well, he does pull a lot of shenanigans that could have ended him up in the Night's Watch. I will say that. Oh, the Night's Watch is a punishment? Yeah, a little bit. Oh. I thought you, like, volunteered. I mean, Jon. Oh, the Night's Watch is a punishment? Yeah, a little bit. Oh, yeah. I thought
你喜欢自愿。我是说，琼恩·雪诺会说，我要去，我想自愿。我以为那就像一个修道院之类的东西。是啊，但他没有地方可去，因为他不是史塔克。所以他不会有头衔或土地。我们要找出他妈妈是谁吗？现在是一个大谜团。最终。好的。我猜当编剧们面试这份工作时，他们见了乔治·R·R·马丁，他给了他们一个测试。他就像，你认为琼恩·雪诺的母亲是谁？
you like volunteer. I mean, Jon Snow is going to be like, I'm going, I want to volunteer. I thought it was like a like a monastery kind of thing. Yeah, but he's he doesn't have anywhere to go, kind of, because he's not a Stark. So he won't have titles or land. Are we going to find out who his mom is? It's a big mystery right now. Eventually. Okay. I guess when the writers were interviewing to do this job, they met with George R.R. Martin, and he kind of gave them like a test. He was like, who do you think Jon Snow's mother is?
你喜欢志愿服务。我的意思是，琼恩·雪诺会说，我要去，我想志愿加入。我原以为那就像某种修道院一样。是的，但他无处可去，因为他不是史塔克家族的人。所以他不会有头衔或土地。我们会知道他妈妈是谁吗？这现在是个大谜团。最终会知道的。好吧。我想当编剧们面试这份工作时，他们见了乔治·R·R·马丁，他给了他们一个测试。他问，你们觉得琼恩·雪诺的母亲是谁？
And they made their guess, and he liked it. I don't know, maybe he had a secret idea all along. Oh. And they made the right guess. I don't know. This is what I read online. Very interesting. Who do you think this article said belongs
他们猜对了，他很喜欢。我不知道，也许他一直有个秘密计划。哦。他们猜对了。我不知道。这是我在网上读到的。非常有趣。你觉得这篇文章说谁属于
to the house Lannister? Angela. No. What? Ryan. Ryan and Kelly. Ah, yes. They said that the Lannisters are all about keeping up
兰尼斯特家族？安吉拉。不。什么？瑞安。瑞安和凯利。啊，是的。他们说兰尼斯特家族的人都很注重
with appearances and they're obsessed with their image. Okay. So, there you go. There you go. Well, I do have a costume catch in this scene. Daenerys has on this sort of very sheer dress. It's see-through.
外表，他们对自己的形象非常痴迷。好吧。所以，就是这样。就是这样。嗯，这一幕里我确实发现了一个服装上的小细节。丹妮莉丝穿的这件裙子非常薄。是透明的。
Yeah. It's not hiding much. But holding the dress up on her shoulders are these elaborate silver sort of like brooches. Yeah. And they have three dragons. They do? Foreshadowing. Three dragon heads make up the brooch.
是的。几乎遮不住什么。但在她肩膀上支撑着裙子的是这些精致的银色胸针。是的。它们有三条龙。真的吗？伏笔。三个龙头像组成了这个胸针。
Interesting. Well, Carl is gonna ride up on his horse. Basically he's just like testosterone on a horse. Yeah. He's played by Jason Momoa. Yes. He has a long braid. Long braid and lots of eyeliner. And when, I guess, in their world,
有趣。好吧，卡奥要骑马过来了。基本上他就像马背上的雄性荷尔蒙。是的。他由杰森·莫玛饰演。是的。他留着长辫子。长辫子，还画了很多眼线。我想，在他们的世界里，
if they are like defeated in a battle, they have to cut their hair. Yeah, cut their ponytail. And his is really long. He's never been defeated. Never been cut. Nope, never been cut. Yeah, and he kind of looks at Daenerys
如果他们在战斗中战败，他们就必须剪掉头发。是的，剪掉马尾辫。他的头发真的很长。他从未战败过。从未被剪过。没错，从未被剪过。是的，他看了丹妮莉丝一眼，
and then he rides away. And Viserys is like, well, what happened? Where's he going? Yeah. And he learns that like, listen, he must have liked her because trust me, if he didn't, we'd know. Yeah. And Daenerys is like, oh, I don't want to get married to this guy. I just want to go home. And he's like, Viserys is like, sister, how?
然后就骑马离开了。韦赛里斯问，怎么了？他去哪儿了？是的。然后他得知，听着，他肯定看上她了，因为相信我，如果他没看上，我们早就知道了。是的。丹妮莉丝说，哦，我不想嫁给这个家伙。我只想回家。韦赛里斯说，妹妹，怎么回？
Where's home? We have no home. That's the whole point. And then he's so mean. I said, this is what I'm calling a major a-hole alert. For sure. He's like, I'd let the whole tribe have their way with you. All 40,000 men, their horses too, if that's what it takes. There is gonna be a really good revenge scene for her with him.
家在哪儿？我们没有家。这才是重点。然后他太刻薄了。我说，这就是我所说的“混蛋警报”。肯定的。他说，我会让整个部落随心所欲地对待你。所有四万名男人，还有他们的马，如果需要的话。她以后会有一场非常精彩的复仇戏。
Oh, I think I remember it. It's in the first couple seasons. Yeah. It was satisfying. Yeah. Amelia Clarke, who plays Daenerys, she just leaps off the screen. She is so great. I know.
哦，我想我记得。在前几季里。是的。那很令人满足。是的。饰演丹妮莉丝的艾米莉亚·克拉克，她简直是从屏幕里跳了出来。她太棒了。我知道。
And she doesn't have a ton of dialogue. And she is just emotes. She's so good. Did you know, though? I was Googling about her. Did you know that she suffered two traumatic brain aneurysms during the filming of Game of Thrones? Yes. Holy ****. I know. She was like carrying around this like secret medical issue. Yeah,
而且她的台词不多。她只是通过表情传达情感。她太棒了。不过你知道吗？我当时在谷歌上搜她。你知道她在拍摄《权力的游戏》期间患了两次创伤性脑动脉瘤吗？是的。天哪。我知道。她就像带着这个秘密的医疗问题。是的，
very scary, life-threatening. Yes. I know. This is what's happening. I'm like not only am I getting caught up on the plot of Game of Thrones, I'm getting caught up on the private lives of all the people who starred in this show. I know. It's a lot of lives that happen. That's like the office. Like people ask us about an episode
非常可怕，危及生命。是的。我知道。这就是正在发生的事情。我不仅在补《权力的游戏》的剧情，还在补这部剧所有主演的私生活。我知道。发生了很多事。就像《办公室》一样。比如人们问我们关于某一集的事情，
and we're like, oh, well this was also happening in my life at the time. Yeah. Well now we're back at Winterfell. Sansa's getting ready for dinner. She wants to know, do you think Joffrey's gonna find her attractive? She really wants to marry him.
我们就会说，哦，当时我生活中也发生了这件事。是的。好了，现在我们回到临冬城。珊莎正在准备晚餐。她想知道，你觉得乔佛里会觉得她有吸引力吗？她真的很想嫁给他。
She does. She's like, says to her mom, I want to be queen. Please, please make father say yes to taking this job as Hand of the King. It's the only thing I've ever wanted. Oh, Sansa. Oh, Sansa. Sam. Sam, if we could go back in time and have a conversation with Sansa. I know. I mean, I saw Joffrey for like four seconds on his horse and I know he's a total dick. Well. Like every other Lannister. It gets so much worse.
她是这么想的。她对她妈妈说，我想成为王后。求求你，求求你让父亲答应接受这个“国王之手”的职位。这是我唯一想要的东西。哦，珊莎。哦，珊莎。山姆。山姆，如果我们能回到过去和珊莎谈谈。我知道。我是说，我只在马背上看了乔佛里四秒钟，我就知道他是个彻头彻尾的混蛋。好吧。就像其他兰尼斯特家族的人一样。情况会变得更糟。
Oh, I know. I saw. I watched. No, no, no. It gets so much worse than you can imagine. No, no, no. Forget Joffrey. Yeah.
哦，我知道。我看到了。我看了。不，不，不。情况比你能想象的还要糟糕得多。不，不，不。忘了乔佛里吧。是的。
Insert absolute human walking nightmare. Oh. Oh. All right. Well, we right. Mm-hmm. Well, we're gonna go to dinner. Cersei has to sit there and watch her husband, like, fill up a waitress. I guess just like one of the bar wenches or something.
插入一个绝对的人形噩梦。哦。哦。好吧，我们对。嗯。好吧，我们要去吃晚餐了。瑟曦不得不坐在那里看着她的丈夫，比如，去应付一个女服务员。我想大概就是酒吧女招待之类的。
Not a waitress, yes. I don't know. And she's just like, she's over it. Yeah, she's so sour all the time. She's super sour, I know. She is the Angela Martin of Game of Thrones. She's very sour. Jon Snow is outside. He's not even in the hall. She is the Angela Martin of Game of Thrones. She's very sour. Jon Snow is outside.
不是女服务员，是的。我不知道。她就是，她受够了。是的，她一直都很刻薄。她超级刻薄，我知道。她是《权力的游戏》里的安吉拉·马丁。她非常刻薄。琼恩·雪诺在外面。他甚至不在大厅里。她是《权力的游戏》里的安吉拉·马丁。她非常刻薄。琼恩·雪诺在外面。
He's not even in the hall. He's practicing his sword skills. And his uncle comes up. It's Uncle Benjen. Okay, so I just want to say I'm really proud that I followed this scene. Okay? Why? What?
他甚至不在大厅里。他在练习剑术。然后他叔叔走过来了。是班扬叔叔。好吧，我只想说，我真的很自豪我跟上了这一幕。好吗？为什么？什么？
So tell me if I got it right. Ned's brother. Yeah. Benjen. Yes. Is part of the Night Watch. Yes. Okay, but you just told me that you had to be like banished to that, but he seems like he is like wears this with honor. Did he do something wrong?
所以告诉我我理解对了吗。奈德的兄弟。是的。班扬。是的。是守夜人的一员。是的。好吧，但你刚才告诉我你必须被流放到那里，但他看起来好像是以此为荣。他做错什么了吗？
I don't know. Sam, do you know? What did Benjen do? How did he end up on the Night's Watch? I don't remember, actually. Okay, well anyway. Do you want me to look that up? How did he end up on the Night's Watch? I don't remember, actually. Okay. Well, anyway, he's... Do you want me to look that up? No, it's not important. I'm just really proud that I know that he works for the Night Watch. Jon Snow wants to work for the Night Watch. Benjen says, don't do it.
我不知道。山姆，你知道吗？班扬做了什么？他怎么会加入守夜人的？其实我不记得了。好吧，总之。你想让我查一下吗？他怎么会加入守夜人的？其实我不记得了。好吧。总之，他……你想让我查一下吗？不，那不重要。我只是很自豪我知道他在为守夜人工作。琼恩·雪诺想为守夜人工作。班扬说，别这么做。
You can't have a family. Jon Snow says, it doesn't matter. I don't have a family anyway. And then he goes inside and then... Wait, wait, but we also find out why John Snow isn't in the party. Because he's not really... No, Caitlin doesn't want him there.
你不能有家庭。琼恩·雪诺说，没关系。反正我也没有家庭。然后他进去了，然后……等等，等等，但我们也发现了为什么琼恩·雪诺不在宴会上。因为他真的……不，凯特琳不想让他去。
She's so tacky. Oh, it's Caitlin? Caitlin! See, I thought I got this scene. You've got so many components of it. But no, Caitlin doesn't want him around. That's another reason he wants to go to the Night's Watch because he's like, Caitlin has it out for me. Also, I just looked it up, Benjen just signed up
她太俗气了。哦，是凯特琳？凯特琳！看，我以为我理解了这一幕。你掌握了其中的很多部分。但不是，凯特琳不想让他待在那儿。这也是他想去守夜人的另一个原因，因为他觉得凯特琳针对他。另外，我刚查了一下，班扬只是报名
and joined the Night's Watch. So you can also just sign up. You can also sign up. My understanding of it is for some people, it's like a calling, a calling of service. Well, Jon Snow is feeling the calling. Yes, but he also doesn't have a lot of options. OK.
然后加入了守夜人。所以你也可以直接报名。你也可以报名。我的理解是，对某些人来说，这是一种召唤，一种服务的召唤。好吧，琼恩·雪诺感受到了这种召唤。是的，但他也没有太多选择。好吧。
And he has, you know, Caitlin, who hates him. And he's not going to inherit any land or titles or anything. Benjen's going to go into the party, and then out of the shadows comes Tyrion. And he says, never forget what you are. You're a bastard. Wear it like armor so it can't be used against you. Yeah.
而且他有，你知道，讨厌他的凯特琳。他也不会继承任何土地或头衔之类的。班扬要进宴会厅了，然后从阴影中走出了提利昂。他说，永远不要忘记你是什么。你是个私生子。把它像盔甲一样穿在身上，这样它就不能被用来对付你了。是的。
And then he has that just heartbreaking line. Yeah, because Jon's like, what would you know about it? And he says, all dwarves are bastards in their father's eyes. Well, when you meet his dad, they are going to have a real rocky relationship. OK. All right.
然后他说了那句令人心碎的台词。是的，因为琼恩问，你对此了解什么？他说，所有的侏儒在父亲眼中都是私生子。好吧，当你见到他父亲时，他们的关系会非常紧张。好吧。好吧。
Well, Benjen's going to go say hi to his brother Ned. And guess what? Benjen knew the guy that Ned beheaded earlier. He said he was a good guy, a true ranger. So now we've got talk of white walkers. We have dire wolves south of the wall. Winter is coming, y'all. Why does no one believe that he saw the white walkers?
好吧，班扬要去和他哥哥奈德打招呼了。你猜怎么着？班扬认识奈德之前斩首的那个人。他说那是个好人，一个真正的游骑兵。所以现在我们开始谈论异鬼了。长城以南有冰原狼。凛冬将至，各位。为什么没人相信他看到了异鬼？
Like, why? Because. Why do we just not believe him? Ned says they haven't been around for 1,000 years. So if they're going to come back, someone has to be the first one to see them. They're not gonna be believed at first. I'm telling you, that's how it works.
比如，为什么？因为。为什么我们就是不相信他？奈德说他们已经一千年没出现过了。所以如果他们要回来，必须有人是第一个看到他们的。起初他们是不会被相信的。我告诉你，事情就是这样运作的。
So the first report of the White Walkers is gonna get dismissed. Yes. How many more are gonna get dismissed? Who knows? I mean, are there really aliens? I don't know. Okay.
所以关于异鬼的第一份报告会被驳回。是的。还会有多少份被驳回？谁知道呢？我是说，真的有外星人吗？我不知道。好吧。
People have said they've seen them, Sam. Honestly, yeah, that tracks. I'm really loving, really loving having Sam here. So I can, cause he's just such my Game of Thrones buddy. Okay. Okay. Sansa, Sansa. Sansa.
人们说他们见过，山姆。老实说，是的，这说得通。我真的很喜欢，真的很喜欢山姆在这里。这样我就可以，因为他简直是我《权力的游戏》的好伙伴。好吧。好吧。珊莎，珊莎。珊莎。
So sorry. Everybody's gonna hate me after this podcast. No they're not. Cause I can't get anyone's name right. You're making such a valiant effort. It's very valuable. You are. And there's gonna be so many people that are gonna be like,
真抱歉。这期播客之后大家都会讨厌我。不，他们不会。因为我记不住任何人的名字。你做出了如此英勇的努力。这非常有价值。你是。而且会有很多人会说，
Jenna, I'm with you, I don't know good with realms. I don't know. I don't know. You just told me. Sansa? Sansa. It's what's interesting to me is that you go a little bit into your fake voice you do for your cats, like your cat, Andi. So you go, Sansa?
珍娜，我和你一样，我不擅长记这些领域。我不知道。我不知道。你刚才告诉过我。珊莎？珊莎。有趣的是，你稍微用了你对猫说话的那种假嗓音，比如你的猫，安迪。所以你说，珊莎？
Sansa? Like, it's just Sansa. Oh, my god. Sansa says, oh my god, I made my dress. I met it. All by myself. Wait, I have an Angela Hot Tip here. What is it? Cersei is going to say, hello, little dove, but you are a beauty. How old are you? Angela Hot Tip. If someone in the Game of Thrones universe calls you Little Dove, buckle in.
珊莎？就像，只是珊莎。天哪。珊莎说，天哪，我做了我的裙子。我做了它。全是我自己做的。等等，我这里有一个安吉拉的小贴士。是什么？瑟曦会说，你好，小鸽子，你真是个美人。你多大了？安吉拉小贴士。如果《权力的游戏》世界里有人叫你小鸽子，系好安全带。
Sh** is about to go down. Really? Yes, it's gonna get real. Okay. Mm-hmm. Well, she's 13. She hasn't had her period yet. Lots of personal questions.
大事要发生了。真的吗？是的，要来真的了。好吧。嗯。好吧，她13岁。她还没来月经。很多私人问题。
Very personal. But then she wants to know if she made her own dress and she's like, I did. And she's like, you should make me one sometime. But it's all like very, like, I'm scared. I'm scared of the queen. I have another Angela hot tip. What?
非常私人。但后来她想知道是不是她自己做的裙子，她说，是我做的。她说，你什么时候也该给我做一件。但这感觉就像，我很害怕。我很怕王后。我还有另一个安吉拉小贴士。什么？
If Cersei pretends to be nice to you, run. Yeah. This is some mean girls BS. Remember in mean girls when she was like, oh, where's your necklace from? It's so fetch or whatever. Yes. No, that means she hates it. She, where's your necklace from? It's so fetch or whatever. Yes. No, that means she hates it.
如果瑟曦假装对你很好，快跑。是的。这简直是《贱女孩》里的烂事。还记得《贱女孩》里她说，哦，你的项链从哪儿买的？太时髦了之类的吗？是的。不，那意味着她讨厌它。她，你的项链从哪儿买的？太时髦了之类的吗？是的。不，那意味着她讨厌它。
She thinks it's horrible. Yes. She didn't like her dress. Sansa, retreat. Yeah. I have an interesting fact that I read. Okay. That I thought you might find interesting, Angela,
她觉得它很糟糕。是的。她不喜欢她的裙子。珊莎，撤退。是的。我读到一个有趣的事实。好吧。我觉得你可能会觉得有趣，安吉拉，
which is that while most married women in the series take on their husband's last name, like Caitlin and Lisa Tully, who took the names Stark and Eren respectively. Circe... Circe? Circe Lannister, who is married to King Baratheon, did not. Baratheon? Jesus!
那就是虽然剧中的大多数已婚女性都冠上丈夫的姓氏，比如凯特琳和莱莎·徒利，她们分别改姓史塔克和艾林。瑟曦……瑟曦？瑟曦·兰尼斯特，她嫁给了拜拉席恩国王，却没有改姓。拜拉席恩？天哪！
I'm watching Jenna shut down in real time. Her body's shutting down. Just say it like Andi. You're closer to the mark. Okay. Okay. I'm just going to call them how I know them. The queen, whose last name is Lannister, did not take her husband's last name. And the reason is that the name of the house
我看着珍娜实时崩溃。她的身体正在崩溃。就像安迪那样说。你离目标更近了。好吧。好吧。我还是按我认识的方式称呼他们。王后，她的姓氏是兰尼斯特，没有改丈夫的姓。原因是家族的名字
that currently holds the Iron Throne can only be inherited through birth. It is not given through marriage. So Sansa? Sansa. If Sansa marries Joffrey, she would still be Sansa Stark. But her child would be be Sansa Stark. But her child would be...
目前拥有铁王座的家族只能通过出生继承。它不是通过婚姻给予的。所以珊莎？珊莎。如果珊莎嫁给乔佛里，她仍然会是珊莎·史塔克。但她的孩子会是……珊莎·史塔克。但她的孩子会是……
A Lannister. Right. Right. When Joffrey becomes king, which is gonna happen really soon. I saw it. This king is like not long for the world. Neither is Ned Stark, by the way.
兰尼斯特。对。对。当乔佛里成为国王时，这很快就会发生。我看到了。这个国王活不长了。顺便说一句，奈德·史塔克也活不长。
And neither is Joffrey, by the way. Joffrey lasts a little longer. A little bit longer. All right. Now we have the weird Jamie, Ned, dick pissing contest. Yes. I didn't get it. I didn't get it. Why? I don't know. He's the queen's brother. That's all he wants to be is literally in the queen. He doesn't want to be hand to the king. Is it that he wants to be king?
顺便说一句，乔佛里也活不长。乔佛里多活了一会儿。多了一点点。好吧，现在我们有了奇怪的詹姆和奈德的“比谁更混蛋”的比赛。是的。我没看懂。我没看懂。为什么？我不知道。他是王后的兄弟。他想要的只是字面意义上地进入王后。他不想当国王之手。是他想当国王吗？
I don't know. That's what he wants. They just, yeah. The Lannisters, they just want a lot. So whatever, the dinner ends. Ned and Kat are in bed now. And he tells her that he belongs up north with her, not down in the capital. And then they are interrupted.
我不知道。那就是他想要的。他们只是，是的。兰尼斯特家族，他们只是想要很多。所以不管怎样，晚餐结束了。奈德和凯特现在在床上。他告诉她，他属于北方，和她在一起，而不是在首都。然后他们被打断了。
There has been a raven. There is a letter. Wait for it. 48 minutes, 43 seconds. Our very first wax seal. We have a 43 seconds. Our very first wax seal. We have a wax seal. We have a wax seal. It's been spotted.
有一只渡鸦。有一封信。等着瞧。48分43秒。我们第一个火漆印。我们有一个43秒。我们第一个火漆印。我们有一个火漆印。我们有一个火漆印。被发现了。
Caitlin opens the letter and all the color drains out of her face. It was sent from the Eyrie. That's where her and her sister are from. And I guess her sister has fled the capital and gone back home because she says John Aaron, who was her husband, was murdered by the Lannisters. And she says King Baratheon is now in danger. Yeah. So Kat takes the letter. I loved it. She goes over, she burns it right away.
凯特琳打开信，脸色瞬间变得苍白。它是从鹰巢城寄来的。那是她和她妹妹的老家。我想她妹妹已经逃离首都回老家了，因为她说琼恩·艾林，也就是她的丈夫，是被兰尼斯特家族谋杀的。她说拜拉席恩国王现在有危险。是的。所以凯特拿走了信。我喜欢这个。她走过去，直接把它烧了。
Oh, I wish we could still do that today. You get a piece of information. I know we delete emails or you can delete a text. It's not the same. Throw it in an actual fire. You know what I would like on my phone? I would like a button that's like a tiny fireplace so that when I delete an email,
哦，我希望我们今天还能那样做。你得到一条信息。我知道我们删除电子邮件或者你可以删除短信。那不一样。把它扔进真正的火里。你知道我手机上想要什么吗？我想要一个像微型壁炉一样的按钮，这样当我删除电子邮件时，
it's like I'm throwing it in a fire. Wouldn't that be fun? I bet you would delete a lot more emails if you threw it in a fire, lady. Yeah, or if there was some sound effect. Yeah. Like if I got satisfaction, if I clicked on it. We could make a lot of money with this idea,
就像我把它扔进火里一样。那不是很酷吗？我敢打赌，如果你把它扔进火里，你会删除更多的电子邮件，女士。是的，或者如果有某种音效。是的。比如如果我点击它，能得到满足感。我们可以用这个点子赚很多钱，
I'm just saying. And we could even like, maybe, like try to link it to Game of Thrones. It could be the, it could be the GOT fire. And that's where like you throw all the stuff you don't want. Maybe it's just a dragon that burns your shit up. Oh yeah. Dragon fire. Dragon fire.
我只是说说。我们甚至可以，也许，试着把它和《权力的游戏》联系起来。它可以是GOT之火。那就是你扔掉所有你不想要的东西的地方。也许它只是一条烧掉你烂事的龙。哦，是的。龙火。龙火。
Well, that's if you really want to burn it. Why wouldn't you really want to burn it? I guess you do. I'm getting rid of stuff. I guess if you burn it in burn it. Why wouldn't you really want to burn it? I'm getting rid of stuff. I guess if you burn it in a fire. I don't want to half-ass burn it. Okay, here's what I wrote. I wrote this. Wait. I literally wrote wait. Kat's sister was the wife of the Hand of the King.
好吧，如果你真的想烧掉它的话。为什么你不想真的烧掉它？我想你是想的。我正在处理掉东西。我想如果你把它烧掉。为什么你不想真的烧掉它？我正在处理掉东西。我想如果你把它烧掉。我不想半途而废地烧掉它。好吧，这是我写的。我写了这个。等等。我真的写了“等等”。凯特的妹妹是国王之手的妻子。
John Aaron's wife. Kat's sister's husband was like a father to Kat's husband Ned. So Ned's brother-in-law was like a father to him, right? The sisters, that means their brothers-in-law's. Ned's sister was the king's special love. Who are the Lannisters and how did they infiltrate this whole system? That's what I wrote down. I think the Lannisters, they just have always had a ton of money.
琼恩·艾林的妻子。凯特妹妹的丈夫就像凯特丈夫奈德的父亲一样。所以奈德的姐夫就像他的父亲，对吧？姐妹们，这意味着她们的姐夫。奈德的妹妹是国王的挚爱。兰尼斯特家族是谁，他们是怎么渗透进整个系统的？这就是我写下来的。我觉得兰尼斯特家族，他们一直都很有钱。
Okay. And money came with the marriages. So probably when he married her, he got some money. 49 minutes and 37 seconds. There are lots of fakey scars on Ned Stark's chest, and I really like this detail of his battle scars. I thought it was cool. Yeah, I like it. Shout out to the battle scars.
好吧。钱是随着婚姻来的。所以可能当他娶她时，他得到了一些钱。49分37秒。奈德·史塔克的胸口有很多假伤疤，我真的很喜欢他战斗伤疤的这个细节。我觉得很酷。是的，我喜欢。为战斗伤疤点赞。
Shout out to the Battle Scars. Shout out to the Battle Scars. We do find out in this scene as well that it is impacted on Ned that the king is in danger. Yeah. This is his childhood friend and there really is no one he can trust and he does need Ned. And now Ned fills the calling
为战斗伤疤点赞。为战斗伤疤点赞。我们也在这一幕中发现，奈德意识到国王有危险。是的。这是他儿时的朋友，真的没有人可以信任，他确实需要奈德。现在奈德履行了召唤，
to go protect his friend and his king. Yeah, but I mean, who are we kidding? He was never gonna say no. He couldn't say no. I know, he was trying to think about it. He was trying to figure out a way to say no. I feel like he was just putting off the inevitable to have like one last good night with Kat
去保护他的朋友和他的国王。是的，但我是说，我们在骗谁呢？他永远不会拒绝。他无法拒绝。我知道，他当时在想这件事。他试图想出一个拒绝的方法。我觉得他只是在推迟不可避免的事情，想和凯特度过最后一个美好的夜晚，
before he had to be like, babe. They were maybe gonna get it on if they weren't interrupted by the Raven. Maybe so, yeah. Or maybe they already had. Maybe they already had. But I think he was- It was a nice night. He was stringing it along.
在他不得不说，宝贝。如果不是被渡鸦打断，他们可能就要亲热了。也许吧，是的。或者他们已经亲热过了。也许他们已经亲热过了。但我认为他——那是个美好的夜晚。他一直在拖延。
Yeah, you didn't want to give the bad news and then kill the mood. All right, now we're going to go to a Dothraki wedding, which was really something. It's like people are dancing, fighting, making out, having sex, all just in one big area. I wrote my thoughts. First I made a list of their wedding gifts
是的，你不想给出坏消息然后破坏气氛。好吧，现在我们要去参加多斯拉克婚礼了，那真是太壮观了。就像人们在跳舞、打架、亲热、做爱，都在同一个大区域里。我写下了我的想法。首先我列出了他们的结婚礼物，
because what's her name? Denarius and Carl are sitting there. Yeah, they're sort of receiving people. Yes, and here's what they got. They got a silver bowl filled with something. They got a chest of snakes. They're just sitting there, they're not talking. They're watching these gifts go by. I wrote, I'm worried she's getting a sunburn on her shoulders.
因为她叫什么名字？丹妮莉丝和卡奥坐在那里。是的，他们算是接待客人。是的，这是他们得到的。他们得到了一个装满东西的银碗。他们得到了一个装满蛇的箱子。他们只是坐在那里，没有说话。他们看着这些礼物经过。我写道，我担心她的肩膀会被晒伤。
Then I wrote, a fight breaks out because two men want to do a humping dance with the same woman. That's true. It turns into a full-on sword fight with sickle swords, and one of the men gets his guts spilled out and dies, oh, and then kind of beheaded. Everyone loves the violence dies, oh, and then kind of beheaded. Everyone loves the violence because, quote,
然后我写道，一场打斗爆发了，因为两个男人想和同一个女人跳“打桩舞”。那是真的。它变成了一场真正的镰刀剑决斗，其中一个人的内脏流了出来，死了，哦，然后被斩首了。每个人都喜欢暴力，因为，引用，
a Dothraki wedding without at least three deaths is considered a dull affair. Yes, I also want to point out that Daenerys has also given a chest with three dragon eggs. Yeah. They've turned to stone, but they're always going to be beautiful, so she's happy about that.
一场没有至少三个人死亡的多斯拉克婚礼被认为是无聊的。是的，我还想指出丹妮莉丝还收到了一个装有三颗龙蛋的箱子。是的。它们变成了石头，但它们永远都很美，所以她对此很高兴。
But wait, before she gets the dragon's eggs, some dude walks up and gives her some books. He gives her the songs and histories from the Seven Kingdoms. And I wrote, do I sense some chemistry? Yes. He's blonde, but I don't think he's a creeper, is what I wrote. No, that's Jorah Mormont.
但等等，在她得到龙蛋之前，有个家伙走过来给了她一些书。他给了她七大王国的歌曲和历史。我写道，我感觉到了一些化学反应吗？是的。他是金发，但我不觉得他是那种变态，这是我写的。不，那是乔拉·莫尔蒙。
And he ends up being like a counselor to her. Yeah. And they have their hills and valleys, but he's a dear friend to her and cares for her. Well, then I wrote, and now here come the eggs, the dragon eggs. I remember these. This is going to be her storyline for the next two years, these eggs and these dragons.
他最终成了她的顾问。是的。他们有起起落落，但他是一个亲爱的朋友，关心她。好吧，然后我写道，现在龙蛋来了，龙蛋。我记得这些。这将是她未来两年的故事线，这些蛋和这些龙。
These dragons, to her, are like these foster kittens that I have. Yes. They're all over her all the time. She's constantly taking care of them. Yes. She is the that I have. Yes. They're all over her all the time. She's constantly taking care of them. Yes, she is the mother of dragons. Yes. That's what she becomes. But then I wrote this.
这些龙，对她来说，就像我养的这些寄养小猫。是的。它们一直都在她身边。她一直在照顾它们。是的。她是——我养的。是的。它们一直都在她身边。她一直在照顾它们。是的，她是龙之母。是的。这就是她后来成为的样子。但后来我写了这个。
Where do they keep all this stuff? Because they're like a traveling society, right? They're nomadic, yeah. So like a good portion of their caravan is just all their crap. Yeah. Like all these wedding gifts, all this stuff. They've just got a cart. A cart they, all these wedding gifts, all this stuff.
他们把所有这些东西都放在哪里？因为他们是一个旅行社会，对吧？他们是游牧民族，是的。所以他们大篷车的一大部分只是他们所有的破烂。是的。就像所有这些结婚礼物，所有这些东西。他们只有一辆马车。一辆他们，所有这些结婚礼物，所有这些东西。
They've just got a cart they have to pull around. Do have to say one thing while we're talking about Dragons. What? Which is, Sam, have you watched House of Dragon? I have, yes. It's so good. It's really good. I love it so much.
他们只有一辆马车要拉着走。在谈论龙的时候，我必须说一件事。什么？那就是，山姆，你看过《龙之家族》吗？我看过，是的。太棒了。真的很好。我非常喜欢它。
It's a prequel. Oh. Well, I wondered from this wedding scene when this guy gets his head sliced open in the fight, I wondered how many prosthetic heads the show has made. There are so many beheadings. I couldn't find out that answer, but the Washington Post did do an article called, quote, an illustrated guide to all 6,887 deaths in Game of Thrones. They break it down by season, deadliest locations and deadliest weapons. Can you guess the deadliest location? King's Landing. It's not. It's not the Red Keep. It's Winterfell.
它是前传。哦。好吧，我从这场婚礼场景中想知道，当这个家伙在打斗中头被切开时，剧组制作了多少个假头。有太多的斩首了。我找不到那个答案，但《华盛顿邮报》确实写了一篇名为《权力的游戏》中所有6887次死亡的图解指南的文章。他们按季节、最致命的地点和最致命的武器进行了分类。你能猜出最致命的地点吗？君临。不是。不是红堡。是临冬城。
Winterfell has a total of 3,709 deaths over the series. King's Landing only has 1,357. Really? That's what like Khaleesi does at the end is only 1,000? That's what it said. Do you know what the deadliest weapon is? Broad sword? Nope. The blade is third with 801 deaths.
临冬城在整个系列中总共有3709次死亡。君临只有1357次。真的吗？这就是龙妈最后做的只有1000次？文章是这么说的。你知道最致命的武器是什么吗？阔剑？不。刀刃排第三，有801次死亡。
A dragon? Yes, an animal. An animal. More people are killed by an animal. It's 1,756 deaths by animal followed by 1,244 by magic. They also have a category for the deadliest killers. This one got me excited. This one, this stat might keep me watching.
龙？是的，动物。动物。更多的人是被动物杀死的。有1756次动物造成的死亡，其次是1244次魔法造成的死亡。他们还有一个最致命杀手的类别。这让我很兴奋。这个统计数据可能会让我继续看下去。
Drogon came in number one. I don't know why it's spelled that way. Is that a thing? The Drogon. Drogon came in number one. I don't know why it's spelled that way. Is that a thing? The Drogon? Drogon. Drogon, they had a picture of a dragon. Is Drogon a special dragon?
卓耿排在第一位。我不知道为什么拼写成那样。那是真的吗？卓耿。卓耿排在第一位。我不知道为什么拼写成那样。那是真的吗？卓耿？卓耿。卓耿，他们有一张龙的照片。卓耿是一条特殊的龙吗？
Yes, very big. Well, Drogon came in number one as the deadliest killer with 1,426 kills. Do you know who got number two? What character is the deadliest killer after Drogon? The Hound? No. The Mountain?
是的，非常大。好吧，卓耿作为最致命的杀手排在第一位，有1426次杀戮。你知道谁排在第二位吗？卓耿之后最致命的杀手是什么角色？猎狗？不。魔山？
No. Ramsay Bolton? 1,278 kills. Khaleesi? Nope. Smoke Guy? They say it's Arya Stark. Oh!
不。拉姆斯·波顿？1278次杀戮。龙妈？不。烟雾怪？他们说是艾莉亚·史塔克。哦！
Oh! Oh. Well, she was with the Man of Many Faces for a while. So that got me excited. I was like, I'll watch that gal. Oh, I know why. I know why Arya. I thought she had like a whole list of shit. That's what I'm trying to act out stuff to you.
哦！哦。好吧，她和千面人待了一段时间。这让我很兴奋。我当时想，我会看那个女孩的。哦，我知道为什么，我知道为什么是艾莉亚。我以为她有一整张烂事清单。这就是我试图向你表演的东西。
I can't see you cause of reflection. Oh, of course Arya. Ugh, duh, okay. Do you know the deadliest season? In season one, there are only 59 deaths. I was gonna say winter, but I guess that's wrong. Season three? No, season eight with 4,548 deaths.
因为反光我看不见你。哦，当然是艾莉亚。呃，废话，好吧。你知道最致命的季节吗？在第一季，只有59次死亡。我本来想说是冬天，但我想那是错的。第三季？不，第八季有4548次死亡。
There you go. Well, here's what's gonna happen now. Yeah. Kaal is done. Kaal is done. Call is done. And I guess his gift to Denarius is this very beautiful white horse that he puts her on, and they're going to ride off. Desarius says, make him happy.
就是这样。好吧，现在要发生什么了。是的。卡奥完了。卡奥完了。卡奥完了。我想他给丹妮莉丝的礼物是这匹非常漂亮的白马，他让她骑上去，他们要骑马离开。丹妮莉丝说，让他开心。
I'm like, shut up, Desarius. Yeah. I noticed this is going to be kind of the first time when we see Emilia Clarke and Jason Momoa standing next to each other when he presents her with this horse. I looked it up. She is five foot two. Jason Momoa is six foot four.
我说，闭嘴，丹妮莉丝。是的。我注意到这是我们第一次看到艾米莉亚·克拉克和杰森·莫玛站在一起，当他把这匹马送给她时。我查了一下。她身高5英尺2英寸。杰森·莫玛身高6英尺4英寸。
Angela Kinsey is five foot one and Rainn Wilson is six foot two. So it's an almost exact height difference by just one inch. They've got one inch on you guys. But then I tried to Google to see if she had to stand on a lot of boxes when she was filming this. I couldn't get a straight answer. But if you ever meet her, it might be something
安吉拉·金赛身高5英尺1英寸，雷恩·威尔逊身高6英尺2英寸。所以身高差几乎完全一样，只差一英寸。他们比你们高一英寸。但我试着谷歌了一下，看看她在拍摄时是否需要站在很多箱子上。我没得到直接的答案。但如果你见过她，这可能是
you guys talk about. I now want to rewatch and just think about how often they would have Rainn Wilson seated and me standing in a scene, because that way they could get us both in frame. So I wonder if Kala's seated a lot. Let's see. Ooh, let's see. and me standing in a scene, because that way they could get us both in frame. Yeah. So I wonder if Carl is seated a lot. Let's see. Ooh, let's see.
你们谈论的事情。我现在想重看一遍，想想他们多久会让雷恩·威尔逊坐着而我站着拍戏，因为这样他们就能把我们俩都拍进画面里。所以我不知道卡奥是不是经常坐着。让我们看看。哦，让我们看看。而我站着拍戏，因为这样他们就能把我们俩都拍进画面里。是的。所以我不知道卡奥是不是经常坐着。让我们看看。哦，让我们看看。
Does that mean you're going to watch more? He he he. I might. Okay. I'm sort of reinvested. I know. Okay. It's the wedding night.
那意味着你要看更多吗？嘿嘿嘿。我可能会。好吧。我算是重新投入了。我知道。好吧。这是新婚之夜。
Wedding night on a cliff on some rocks? Yeah. There's not even a bed. There's, it's not great. There's nothing cozy and intimate about this. I want to tell you, I was really rooting for Call to be like this sensitive and attentive lover.
新婚之夜在悬崖上的岩石上？是的。甚至没有床。没有，这不太好。这没什么舒适和亲密可言。我想告诉你，我真的很支持卡奥成为那种敏感和体贴的情人。
I wanted him to go against type, you know? I just think it would have been a cool twist. Instead, he is not sensitive and he rapes her on these rocks. I looked this up and in the book, he's very gentle. And it's what I wanted. He waits until Daenerys warms up to him. She consents by putting his hand between her thighs. She enjoys the sex.
我希望他能反其道而行之，你知道吗？我觉得那会是一个很酷的转折。相反，他并不敏感，他在这些岩石上强奸了她。我查了一下，在书里，他非常温柔。这就是我想要的。他等到丹妮莉丝对他产生好感。她通过把他的手放在她大腿之间来表示同意。她享受性爱。
And that in the unseen pilot of the show, they went with a scene that was more like the one in the book. But when asked about changing it for Winter is Coming, George R.R. Martin said, "'Ultimately you would have to ask the showrunners because it wasn't his idea. But it has been speculated that given the forced nature
而在该剧未播出的试播集中，他们采用了一个更像书中的场景。但当被问及为什么为《凛冬将至》改变它时，乔治·R·R·马丁说：“最终你得去问剧集主管，因为那不是他的主意。但据推测，考虑到婚礼的强迫性质
of the wedding and Daenerys' young age, that modern audiences would not have accepted the sex as consensual and they chose to depict it as forced. Clarke believed that the rape and Viserius' abuse were instrumental in building up empathy for her character and for her eventual, I believe, she has a comeuppance. I didn't know that it was written differently. And there is a storyline where she sort of tells him, like, this is not how we're going to do this.
和丹妮莉丝的年轻，现代观众不会接受这种性行为是自愿的，他们选择将其描绘成强迫的。克拉克认为，强奸和韦赛里斯的虐待对于建立对她角色的同情以及她最终的，我相信，她有报应。我不知道它是以不同方式写的。而且有一个故事情节是她告诉他，比如，这不是我们要做的方式。
I feel like I remember that. I feel like there's this moment where she is like, I believe this can be pleasurable for both of us. Am I remembering this right? You are. You are. I feel like I remember that. I feel like there's this moment where she is like, I believe this can be pleasurable for both of us. Am I remembering this right? You are. And they start, like, becoming, like, lovers. And they fall in love.
我觉得我记得那个。我觉得有这样一个时刻，她就像，我相信这可以让我们双方都感到愉悦。我记得对吗？你是对的。你是对的。我觉得我记得那个。我觉得有这样一个时刻，她就像，我相信这可以让我们双方都感到愉悦。我记得对吗？你是对的。然后他们开始，比如，成为，比如，恋人。然后他们坠入爱河。
She loves him. Yeah. I thought so. And so there is this scene where she's kind of learned from her ladies of court, if you will, in the Dothraki. She has women that sort of tend to her. And she's like, I don't know anything about sex. This is all I know, there's gotta be more.
她爱他。是的。我想是这样。所以有这样一个场景，她从多斯拉克宫廷的女士们那里学到了东西，如果你愿意的话。她有照顾她的女性。她说，我对性一无所知。我只知道这些，一定还有更多。
And so he comes to her one night and literally she just stops him and is like, no, we're not doing it this way anymore. And then it's like they- It's on. It's on. They're really invested in each other. And he kind of learns that like, oh, maybe I didn't know this is how you could be
所以他有一天晚上来找她，她真的只是阻止了他，说，不，我们不能再这样做了。然后就像他们——开始了。开始了。他们真的投入到了彼此身上。他有点意识到，比如，哦，也许我不知道这就是你可以
with someone, you know, kind of thing. I remember watching it the first time and being like slightly conflicted about that whole storyline. I was like, this feels like very- Well, they could have just started that way. Yeah. They could have just started.
和某人在一起的方式，你知道，那种事情。我记得第一次看的时候，对整个故事情节感到有点矛盾。我当时想，这感觉非常——好吧，他们本可以一开始就那样。是的。他们本可以一开始就那样。
I like the against type thing of like- That's what- He seems gruff on the exterior, but now this is his wife and he's gonna take care of her. Well, we're not done with- Disturbing sexual encounters. Exactly. Well, wait, before we get there,
我喜欢那种反其道而行之的感觉，比如——那就是——他外表看起来很粗鲁，但现在这是他的妻子，他会照顾她。好吧，我们还没完——令人不安的性遭遇。没错。好吧，等等，在我们到那儿之前，
we do have a scene between Ned and the king and they're about to go hunting and King Robert just says, thank you. Thank you for being my hand to the king and that he says you are my last loyal friend. So yeah, now we're up in the tower. We're up in the tower. Bran is scaling the wall once again.
我们确实有一个奈德和国王之间的场景，他们正准备去打猎，罗伯特国王只是说，谢谢。谢谢你成为我的国王之手，他说你是我就剩的最后一个忠诚的朋友。所以是的，现在我们在塔楼里。我们在塔楼里。布兰又一次在爬墙。
He's climbing up to the very top wall and he looks in and what does he see? Jaime and Cersei. They are getting it on. They're getting it on. They both look up and see him. Because he's doing a horrible job of peeping. How long did he need to watch that?
他爬到了最高处的墙上，他往里看，他看到了什么？詹姆和瑟曦。他们在亲热。他们在亲热。他们俩都抬头看到了他。因为他偷窥的工作做得太烂了。他需要看多久？
I don't know. He's like caught, he's busted, and Jamie grabs him and has him, like by the shirt, and he's kind of half hanging out the window. Yeah. And Jamie's gonna just tell him, like, hey, get out of here. Jamie's not going to hurt him. But then Cersei over and over is like, he saw, he saw. And she's basically saying to him, he cannot have witnessed this.
我不知道。他就像被抓住了，他被逮到了，詹姆抓住他，把他，比如抓住衬衫，他半个身子挂在窗外。是的。詹姆只是要告诉他，比如，嘿，离开这里。詹姆不会伤害他。但瑟曦一遍又一遍地说，他看到了，他看到了。她基本上是在对他说，他不可能目睹了这一切。
Do we think this is why they killed John Aaron too, is because John Aaron was onto them? Because they sort of allude to that. They're like, what if he told? Yeah, no, for sure John Aaron found out. For sure, I think. OK, OK. So many people have to die to keep this secret. Secret, yeah.
我们认为这就是他们杀死琼恩·艾林的原因吗，是因为琼恩·艾林发现了他们？因为他们暗示了这一点。他们就像，如果他说了怎么办？是的，不，肯定琼恩·艾林发现了。肯定，我想。好吧，好吧。为了保守这个秘密，这么多人必须死。秘密，是的。
Well, Jamie, like, shoves him out the window. And you don't know what happens to Bran. And then he sort of casually turns to Cersei and say, oh, the things we do for love. And that's the end of the episode. And that's the end of the episode. That's it. That's it.
好吧，詹姆，比如，把他推下窗户。你不知道布兰发生了什么。然后他随意地转向瑟曦说，哦，我们为爱所做的事。这就是这一集的结尾。这就是这一集的结尾。就是这样。就是这样。
That was so fun. And thank you for watching it, Jenna. That's it. That was so fun. And thank you for watching it, Jenna. I think maybe now I owe you one. Mm. Mm. Oh no. You know what?
那太有趣了。谢谢你观看它，珍娜。就是这样。那太有趣了。谢谢你观看它，珍娜。我想也许现在我欠你一次。嗯。嗯。哦，不。你知道吗？
Will you all write in and say, what should I pick for Angela to watch now? Be nice, y'all. I don't know. I mean, you already watched The Edge for me. Yeah. So that's all I could ever really ask for. I feel satisfied. Really?
你们都写信来说，我接下来该选什么让安吉拉看？善良点，各位。我不知道。我是说，你已经为我看了《边缘》。是的。所以我能要求的也就这些了。我觉得很满足。真的吗？
I do. Yeah. I have so many things I want you to watch. Okay. Well, maybe I'll have to watch another one of yours. Okay. I really can't believe you haven't seen Pride and Prejudice. Oh, yes. I need that to happen in my life. Of course. Well, I have to decide now
我确实。是的。我有很多东西想让你看。好吧。好吧，也许我得看另一部你的。好吧。我真的不敢相信你没看过《傲慢与偏见》。哦，是的。我需要那件事发生在我的生活中。当然。好吧，我现在得决定
if I've gotten roped back into the Game of Thrones story, which I don't know. I just know what's going to happen, which is that all of these terrible people are going to keep doing terrible things and they're going to kill all the people I like. And I just don't know if I can go down that road again. Well, when you put it that way. All right, well you guys write in, let us know if there's something you want me to watch. Maybe Jenna, we can take a break from Game of Thrones. I'm not gonna give up on it with you and maybe we watch Pride and Prejudice.
我是否又被卷回了《权力的游戏》的故事中，我不知道。我只知道会发生什么，那就是所有这些可怕的人会继续做可怕的事情，他们会杀死所有我喜欢的人。我只是不知道我是否能再次走那条路。好吧，当你这么说的时候。好吧，你们写信来，让我们知道有什么你想让我看的。也许珍娜，我们可以从《权力的游戏》中休息一下。我不会和你放弃它的，也许我们看《傲慢与偏见》。
I would be up for that. All right. Well, listen everyone, thank you for tuning in to Office Ladies' due Game of Thrones. Next time we might do Pride and Prejudice. See you then. Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
我会同意的。好吧。好吧，听着，大家，感谢收听《办公室女士》之《权力的游戏》。下次我们可能会看《傲慢与偏见》。到时候见。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。